going to open the public hearing
on senate bill 431 and i will call
senator carson
good morning madam chair and good
morning members of the house children
and family law committee for the record
my name is sharon carson and i have the
pleasure of representing senate district
14 comprising the towns of londonderry
hudson and auburn and i have for your
consideration this morning senate bill
431 relative to child support cases and
equal are approximately scheduled
the bill establishes methods for the
adjustment of child support for equal
again or approximately equal parenting
residential responsibilities
this
this legislation it comes from the
child support working group if you
remember last year we had quite a few
bills dealing with this particular issue
and ms honey hastings who was here today
and is going to be testifying offered at
that point to put together a child
support working group of professionals
to address this issue and the
legislation that you have in front of
you is the result of that
working group's uh efforts
so at this point i am going to conclude
my testimony
the working group members are here and
they will be able to walk you through
this bill much better than i can
thank you very much madam chair
are you taking any questions or no no
so then i'm gonna thank you very much
thank you very much madam chair i'm
gonna go ahead and call up um honey
hastings
first
she said she needs six minutes to speak
and she does have written testimony
madam chairman members of the committee
i'm from temple
i
spent about 34 years of family law
lawyer and 22 years which continue as a
certified family mediator
you may remember some of you were around
in in 2018 when we had the alimony
working group and this was uh this is a
similar group somewhat overlapping in
membership
oh i forgot to mention i think the first
time i was privileged to testify before
this committee was 1987
when the you were considering
uh codifying the property of vision law
and it passed and i think has worked
the child support working group and i've
my testimony has a description of the
group and lists the names of people at
the bottom three of us are here today
to testify
brought together our years of experience
i think i must have done
over a thousand cases over my years of
experience so and i represented dads i
represented moms
in the early years i represented a lot
of dads
in
primary parenting cases
because that was considered unusual in
and since i've been doing mediation i
have been a neutral between lots and
lots of parents
and try to get them to an agreement
and
what came out of our looking at what the
bills from last year is a need to focus
on one problem that
perhaps could have an easy fix without a
big study but it needed some study and
that was what to do in the equal and
approximately equal cases
our goal was to clarify the law because
the law does spell out what to do
but it could be clearer
please note that approximately what
child child support is going to
be and all the other issues
and the 10 percent that don't have a
settlement not all the issues are about
child support some of those people
settled child support and are fighting
about the pension or the vacation home
or alimony although not so much in
recent years
when you hear about litigated cases
this is one person's experience
and i think you should weigh it
accordingly
we thought the first thing to do was to
figure out
what was important what was the criteria
we wanted to apply
uh in in finding a method and we
it's shown on page two of my
my
written testimony that we came up with
this test that was first thing fair to
the child
child support is about children
it's not about pay yours and payees
and the current statute says
the purpose of child support is to
minimize economic consequences to
children so we felt that that was
clearly the first priority
the next was a reasonable lifestyle for
the child in each home
right now that's in the law as
a test that says to meet the cost of
child rearing in a similar approximate
equal style to the other parent
so those two tests were those two
factors are in the current law and we
thought they were good ones
we thought it was important that it be
understandable even to self-represented
parties
and we thought it should distinguish
between those cases where guidelines
child support is appropriate
in light of fair to the child and
reasonable lifestyle and those that need
an adjustment and we felt it should
continue the long-standing requirement
of equal or approximately equal
so with those in mind we started uh
exploring what the options were to be
frank we we started early on looking at
the bill that representative desimone
put forward which would use net the
difference
in all equal time cases
um
i had used that test i'd used that
process for at least 20 years maybe
longer other members of our our group
had also used it inappropriate cases in
other words it was a settlement tool
it has a lot to be said for it it's
simple it's straightforward it's easy to
understand but when we got into it more
and tony matrimo who's here on our team
will explain how we got to the fact that
we concluded it wasn't fair to children
when the parents incomes were
substantially different
so
um yes not the difference but but
limiting where it comes from i'd like to
just go over the bill and touch on some
high points
first we collected
all the
components that deal with
making adjustments to guidelines because
of equal or approximate equal into one
new section labeled
5a 458 c 5a you'll see it start on page
one section four line four so all the
material that has to do with this
concept is in one place it's not the way
the law is now this we thought would be
easier to follow
we start with equal or approximately
equal you might say what's that mean
well i can tell you
it doesn't mean 51
to 60 it means equal or approximately
equal it's hard to give a number of
overnights which some would do because
that is not the whole test of equal or
approximately equal for instance there
might be
a 40
60 overnight but there might be
every after school day afternoon with a
40 percent parent
so but because of work schedules the
overnights are not so closely split so
our view was
the courts seem to have been able to
recognize equal and approximately equal
it's been the law for some time and we
just stick with that
so we put in there
a new test
of for varying because of equal schedule
which is
best interest of the child
and meeting the costs of child rearing
in a similar approximate equal style you
recall that's similar to one of the
tests now
our tests eliminate any reference to
fixed cost because it seemed to be
less useful
more
problematic
in starting on line 14
section 3
there's an optional test
if the court thinks it is useful
in considering whether the style
lifestyle is similar they don't have to
use it it's not required in every test
and
then looking further down
line 24 this is the existing law that
when ruling on these requests for
deviation because of approximate equal
schedule
they can look at whether the parties
have allocated expenses
what we added in there is on line 27
and they have provided a specific
procedure for implementing the
apportionment it is problematic when
people say we'll just split all expenses
or we'll just spit all you know
extracurriculars
and they don't have a method spelled out
so by
asking people to put in how they're
going to do it maybe they're going to
keep a joint account and need to put
money into it and use
debit cards to take money out of it to
pay for the extracurricular
maybe one parent is going to handle
expenses a b and c and the other
parent's going to ha and all expenses d
e and f
some plan for how it'll be doing because
we've seen that that can lead to our
fights
we've given a definition of variable
expenses just because there seemed to be
some confusion people didn't know what
variable expenses were or the difference
between variable and fixed so we just
we're trying to clarify the law by
defining them
looking at page two line three here's
something we added if the court is
making an adjustment because of equal
schedule
then the court needs to allocate the
cost of day care after school vacation
etc some
summer care unless the parties have done
so here's the problem
currently if you have guidelines the
person receiving the guidelines is
supposed to pay such expenses
but if it's not guidelines that
presumption may be inappropriate
and we're saying if you're going to
lessen the support then just say who's
going to pay which of these expenses
which is i'm sure you all know have only
increased in new hampshire
line six on page two starts out and
explains the net the difference so what
you do
you use the worksheet and i think you'll
be getting worksheets uh in a few
minutes from tony um
you take there's a point on the
worksheet where it says
when we look at the the parents
proportional incomes this is the portion
of the child support that is
attributable to one parent and then to
the other and it gives a percentage um
so
you can look at the worksheet and you
can see right off whether
it's more 60 or more or it's less
so what we're saying is in cases where
the differences between the incomes is
such that one parent's
income
is
less than 60 percent of the total that
was based on our experiment of doing
multiple uh scenarios and playing them
out
then you take the support that the form
gives you already the form gives us for
the high income parent
and the
low-income parents subtract the lower
from the higher and that number is the
net the difference number and that's
what would be paid by the high-income
person this seems to work and come out
with fair results which tony will say
more about in these in this um income
situation
um
so i think that's uh a review of the
bill i'm open to questions madam chair
should there be any from the committee
uh representative yokela thank you thank
you for taking the question
um
how did you decide
what um
well what criteria did you decide for
this uh working group a membership
and did you request uh or
do you uh reach out to the public um
because i don't see any um
families or
or judges um on this well judges would
not participate in such things they have
to stay apart from any more than they'd
be on a committee your your you would
set up um i spoke with the people who
had
been with the alimony group and looked
out for more people with a lot of
experience helping people settle these
cases and that's how
i
invited tony to come on it because he is
a professional mediator who spends every
day
helping people settle their divorce and
parenting cases and while i'm kind of
semi-retired and maybe have done a
couple dozen cases in the last couple
years
i don't know i think he's done hundreds
so he has seen people
parents as a neutral he has seen parents
struggle with this question helps them
with their financial forms and what what
is the need how do we get the child
taken care of in both homes with
reasonable lifestyle and he seems to
have a pretty good success rate he'll
tell you more
you know i see this as challenging but
maybe it's my lesser skills in mediation
he seems to be generally successful in
getting people to come up with a
solution
so we didn't put a call out if that's
what you're asking we look for people
that had
lots of experience uh in in doing this
kind of work because if i've had a
thousand cases experience and someone
else in the group has had 1500 or more
and someone else has done
you know the total number of cases that
we're bringing to it is really different
uh we knew that
when we got here to te you know to
having a hearing when you had a hearing
that you would be reaching out in a
different way and would have
parents but each parent just gives his
experience or her experience of one case
and without having the case file and
reading it
maybe even listening to the testimony if
it was recorded you can't really know
what what happened there
thank you so
i
i guess to summarize the question it was
uh the criteria was that you
you uh just looked in
for the people that you knew that that
had experience in this and you chose the
people to be on this working group is
that
correct people volunteered
uh as you see looking at the bottom of
my testimony it's on page four we have
uh mary krueger who is here today
um and aaron jacina and they are with
new hampshire legal assistants
representing uh many
um uh
impoverished people in divorce marilyn
mahoney is
not here today because she had a
conflict but she has experience similar
to mine i think we both testified in 87
on that property bill has been
interested and testified on a lot of
policy questions
um as i mentioned i invited tony because
he's doing so much mediation and william
woodbury is uh
more of a generalist but does a lot of
family law and he's active in the new
hampshire association for justice so we
tried to get a diverse group didn't say
no to anybody but really we just needed
people who are willing to spend a lot of
time
i mean i think the amount of hours we
spent in the last week
would be um
i'm sure i spent the equivalent of a day
and a half you know
30 hours or more myself and other people
spent some more time people who had the
time a couple retired lawyers a couple
of lawyers currently in practice so we
wouldn't have stale information
full-time mediator
you know
i follow up
it's actually a new line of questioning
oh new line of collection
thank you
um
when you say uh
that they
that the parents would have equal
capacity to
raise their child
were there any
factors other than monetary that you
brought into that
equation
this was thank you for your question
this was not a bill about how to assign
parenting time again keep in mind
approximately 90 of parents get this
sorted out
less than 10
and i would say as to parenting probably
the percentage that settle or is even
higher i was talking about divorces
overall
but as to parenting most parents
who are certainly the specialists on
their children
make those decisions they may need some
help
with a case manager or a mediator in
saying you haven't done anything about
vacations won't there be vacations what
kind of schedule will you have that or
will the schedule be different in the
summer than it is in the school year
but they know the basic schedule
and hopefully they've actually been
living it for a month or two before they
write it down or carve it into the
granite for the through age 18.
one more follow-up other people have
questions yeah sure thank you um
what um
so one of the things that is currently
um in child support is that um
they're trying to figure out how much of
the the
combined income would go towards the
raising of the child
um or the
how much money of that would go towards
the raising of the child and um in
shared and equal parenting time
or approximately equal parenting time um
some of that that
money
would be spent while the person is
actually parenting and so
um
i guess my question is did when you were
considering
the um
the factors as far as
what is appropriate for
um
each person to be
required to pay the other person did the
amount that the money that they spent
actually raising the child
come into play in some way
i know
the other bill that you spoke testified
about and i was able to listen to your
testimony
was dealing with changing the
percentages
of the tables but let me say this that
since we've had the guidelines which is
the parent paying guidelines has always
paid has always spent more money on kids
than the guidelines this idea that that
number on the child support worksheet is
the you can't have require anyone to
spend a dollar more than what's on there
it's just not been the experience in new
hampshire
people paid the guidelines amount to the
other parent in kind of traditional
schedules we're not talking about the
equal time schedule so much but
and they've always when they had the
child say in a traditional schedule of
alternate weekends and wednesday
overnight
then they still fed the kids on the
alternate weekends with their additional
money over what they had given to the
other parent
and on wednesday night and they took the
kids out for pizza or they went uh and
did some sport event with the children
this has always been so
it's
the idea that
they should not spend anything more on
the kids is
i think is not child focused and when
you come to equal time schedules
you have the additional consideration of
it's not it costs more to raise children
in two homes than in one
and that's why
the
unh report
i have some criticism but on this point
they're right it costs more if the kids
are have to be
outfitted with everything in both houses
they called for using a multiplier that
issue calculate the child support in the
usual fashion and you multiply that
child support number that guidelines
number by
1.5
to account for the fact that it takes
more to support kids in two households
and then a portion only then apportioned
it between the children and
that was in 1647 as introduced but
your amendment representative ukela
removed the 1.5 multiplier so that
that's a further problem it takes more
and it it takes more than guidelines to
raise a child especially if two
households have to be fully outfitted
representative de simone
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
taking into consideration your last
statement of it does cost more to
provide two homes for children i'm
looking at um on page one
uh line 28 roman numeral
six and
page two
uh line three
it says here that
the variable expenses include but are
not limited to education
school supplies day care after school
programs vacation
in summer care
so taking into consideration the
additional costs of running two homes
for these children
why would we make it a law
that specifically states
that if johnny wants to go to hawaii for
vacation
one or the other parent has to pay for
that
i don't i don't see where after school
programs vacation and
summer camp should be included in the
law can you explain the thought process
there please thank you uh thank you for
your question representative di simone
so it appears that your question
primarily uh
is talking about what is on page
three that is
when the child support is adjusted that
these list these kind of child care
things need to be considered am i right
that your question primarily applies to
that
no it applies primarily to things like
um
vacations
uh
summer camp
driver's education
if one person disagrees that
vacation is
is paramount to the child's well-being
or driver's education why would we put
that in law that should be something
that should
be agreed upon between the parents and
maybe a mediator
would you agree
well mediators don't make decisions for
parents we help them come to the
decision
um
so let i'm happy to clarify that
so
the part that's on line 28 of of the
first page
which is essentially a definition of
variable expenses really relates to the
prior section five
so in ruling on requests for adjustment
because of the equal schedule the court
may doesn't have to may consider whether
the parties have agreed to specific
apportionment of variable expenses
and a procedure for for um implementing
that
so
this is
um if someone's requesting uh variation
from the guidelines
the court can consider and this i think
would come up primarily in cases where
the parties in fact have agreed to a
deviation
you can't just have in my experience as
a media i can't just say the parties
don't want to do guidelines
i have to put why i have to justify it
under the current law like shared
schedule and agreement to split these
costs that's the kind of thing i write
in the uniform support order
i don't know that the court would
approve
a non-guidelines order if i didn't write
in the reasons
so that the the fact that apportionment
of ex variable expenses is
something that can be used to justify a
variation in the guidelines
but they came to be as you've seen and
i've seen over the testimony recently of
the various child support bills
and because of silva
what is what is a variable expense so we
just simply said here's what we're
talking about so if if the parties are
saying please approve this we've already
sorted out all the expenses
then the court would be able to say
okay i've seen you've done that and as
to
uh the part that's on page three roman
um numeral uh seven
here's here's the the concern as i said
right now there's a presumption of how
those daycare costs are met the person
getting this the guideline support gets
it
but it's not clear what happens if
there's not guideline support
and you know the allocation may be
equal sharing of it and and it's if they
agree to it i mean if in fact there's no
after-school care because
the people kids are teens
or
the little ones are with one of the
grandmoms who doesn't ask for any money
then it's there's no cost but if there
is a cost
and for most families there is a cost
which is only increasing each week it
seems then
the qu we're saying the court can't
um
adjust the child support without
deciding that one way or another it may
be that one parent still has enough to
pay the whole cost and maybe you want to
take those percentages on the worksheet
and divide up the child care you know 60
40 or whatever the percentages were so
this does not require anyone to approve
of vacations
or any of those other things it's just
if if they do
agree on that then that could be a
factor in approving
yeah you can definitely say no to no
vacations i mean no summer camp
i want the kids to stay home that's a
parental decision
representative belanger
thank you madam chair
thank you for being here and providing
your testimony today
barring any unforeseen domestic violence
or any issues right assuming that a
family is
let's say normal i'm putting that in air
quotes
right
um
do you agree that if there are two
parents
um
in a situation
taking out any negative scenario
that they should be sharing
custody
time parenting time thank you i'm sorry
i was just going to
i got it
thank you if we could only get the
supreme court to use the right words um
i don't dare correct them
i wrote i wrote the parental rights and
responsibilities act that got rid of
custody
so i i kind of take it personally
parents very few parents fail to share
the care of their children
sharing doesn't mean 50 50.
most parents work out the plan for the
and the timing of
the sharing
so i think
unless there's some very good reason
someone is incarcerated um there's been
violence particularly violence against
the children
um
someone is stationed in the far east
absent some reason like that well it's
it's written in the parental rights and
responsibilities law
most kids do better when they have
frequent irregular contact with both
parents i believe that i believe that
but most parents do not choose a 50 50
schedule an increasing number to do
compared to
1982 when i started practicing
and the male lawyers in my in nashua
wouldn't take a guy who wanted
sharing or more custody which we had
then um because they couldn't understand
why he'd want it
but things have changed society has
changed and i think it's for the benefit
of children some people work in boston
and have a long commute
the other the other parent hopefully has
stayed
with a maybe parents hours job locally
or a job from home and so to say that
the time has to be equal i don't know
how you do it one parent is simply not
as available
um
there are the schedules of um
uniform services which have a rotating
schedule it's really
challenging to come up with a time
but it's typically
following something that has been worked
out in terms of the work schedules and
availability of each parent there are
also some parents
who don't want parenting as much as
public policy would say would be good
for children and i think that's
regrettable
but that is true
i think it's usually though
practicalities including work schedules
that mean a 50 50 schedule just simply
won't work for all parents
they decide if they decide
alternate weekends wednesday night but
more time in the summer is what works
for them who are we to say no you must
have the children fifty percent of the
time
representative all chiller
i'm sorry follow up
sorry
thank you madam chair thank you for your
question i think
all right thank you for your answer
sorry
i'm not here today either
um i'll thank you for your question
which has got me thinking dealing with
stuff at work it's not great um ah so
in my in and i'm gonna preface this so
in my instance um i own a business
right and
you know i may pay for everything but
what you alluded to was that it is more
costly to
to provide two homes so my expectation
is while i see my kids on a regular
basis now of course my wife and i aren't
separated but in the instance that we
were my expectation would be to be
paying for both of these houses i'm
still seeing both my kids but
i mean we've got to figure out a way to
to drop this down but in in the instance
that it cost
um
to your point where you said it cost
more to
have two homes to pay for two homes
is is it your expectation that if a
parent is
sharing equal parenting time
i said that right that time good that
they're
not paying
as much for child support
i think what we need is what's fair to
kids and if what's fair to kids again i
don't see the guidelines number as a
magic number and it would be against
public policy for parents to spend any
more on their children than what the
guidelines number produces because since
guidelines paying parents have still fed
their children during their
time which used to be called visitation
but of course we don't use that word
either
so i don't think it's harmful if you
look at and i know the courts would
look at the budgets of both household
look at the income when the income is so
much
higher after paying guidelines support
the hi the high income parent
in most scenarios is still going to have
more available income after child
support than the parent who receives
child support you need to look at
examples and again i
tony will say more about that and has an
exhibit that talks about that more so
i hope you'll ask some of those
questions again with with his material
in hand
okay
okay representative all chiller
thank you madam chair and thank you very
much for being here today i wouldn't i
want to dial back
um and just for a clarification
in current statute
in 458 c
part a which reflects
this bill as amended by the senate lines
28 and 29 i want to clarify that the
variable expenses the first seven are
include but aren't limited to education
school supplies day care after school
programs
and then the
the words here are vacation and summer
care
then followed by extracurricular
activity so vacation and summer care
is actually referencing when schools are
not in session that's right and thank
you for calling that to my attention i
didn't catch that
when i was trying to answer
representative simone's question uh but
it's talking about um february vacation
april vacation
um
and and again those are
some of the biggest out-of-pocket
expenses parents have
you know that if you have kids or
grandkids uh so
um that that's just huge especially the
little kids
right so may finish my question so my
my question
in pointing that out was if one of the
one of the parents
has the available um
disposable income to take
their children on a vacation up to lake
winnipesaukee during the summer and the
other parent does not have the
disposable income
to take their children on a vacation up
to lake winnipesaukee for the summer
this bill does not require that the
parent with that disposable income
provide that to the parent that doesn't
so that they each get an equal vacation
correct correct okay thank you very much
do you have a question anybody else
all right seeing that oh okay
representative we're really running
short on time so
now that we are uh
i now that um
everyone else has a chance um i had a
question about um
you mentioned this uh that the cost
um for having two households is
is increased
and
how is that
um
dealt with in this proposed legislation
as far as the increased costs
um
being
necessary for to
to income household especially how does
it address the increased costs
with
people that have
let's say
of a difference
of income
uh 61 49
well
thank you that's uh for your question
what we what we found in the examples
please ask them when you have the
scenarios um
is at that income level at 60 or more
after that parent paid the guidelines
which would enable the other parent to
maintain the children
the uh the guidelines payer still had
more money
than the lower income parent
still had more and yes
again
it would require paying dollars that are
not
in the guidelines numbers i said that i
think it's a mistaken idea that that's
the limit on what parents could spend
so yes but there's enough and
that higher income person by our
calculations had enough
to
support him or herself and the children
because the income was so much higher
yes more than the guidelines could be
spent
follow-up thank you um
would you agree that
that this
that the guidelines are
not a maximum amount but actually a
minimum amount that is required to be
spent
because that is what is
required to be paid to the
um other person that is available for
that money to be spent on the children
i certainly agree that it's not the
maximum
um i wouldn't say it's the minimum
because in fact this bill proposes cases
where the guidelines would not be paid
so in cases that
under our bill
guidelines should be used then i guess
it could be except there are other
factors in 458
5 for varying from the guidelines other
than parenting time and it has to do
with
extraordinary health expenses the cost
of college of kids i don't remember the
whole list but there's there's four or
five other factors that could be uh
you know a very high income a very low
income those also are reasons for
varying so the guidelines are kind of
what they say guidelines
one more follow-up thank you um
in in um
referencing to this variable expenses
and uh deviations
um
could
someone
um
where they haven't agreed
where one parent is going to hawaii
and
and request the the court to
um
to have a deviation because they hold on
one second because they address that
this is not regarding a vacation going
somewhere it's regarding school
vacations that's
would you agree that it says other child
related expenses and not limited to oh i
would agree okay thank you
um so that's not what you were asking so
so would you um agree that
that they don't have to agree about the
variable expense before they go to court
to request a deviation for
that variable expense cost
they don't have to ever agree on
variable expenses but they can't use it
as a factor to justify an exception to
the guidelines unless they agree we
haven't changed the law on this as far
as the court deciding about variable
expenses
except
daycare which we've indicated the court
has to do that if it deviates if it
doesn't deviate it doesn't have to
allocate the daycare expenses
thank you very much for your testimony
for the rest of the people who i have
cards for i just ask that you do not
repeat what has already been said
okay because we we delved into a lot
there so up next will be anthony
mattremolo
from the child support did i butcher
that i'm so sorry
he's asked for five minutes
oh and do you have is that
written testimony
okay
good morning i want to thank everyone
for giving me the opportunity to speak
today
my name is anthony matramalo i am a
certified family mediator
my
my experience is i work with families
every single day in my office
dealing with this
issue
there it is rare that a day goes by that
i'm not talking about child support or
parenting
with multiple families in my office each
day
the my i have served as the president of
the new hampshire conflict resolution
association
i was appointed by the governor to serve
on the family mediator certification
board
i have a lot of experience working with
people on
families that's the overwhelming
majority of my practice is family
family loft situations
and i was asked to join this group
[Music]
honey hastings approached me
she knew me from my
as a mediator
and asked me if i would be willing to
spend some time working on this issue
because this had there had been bills
that had been introduced that
that
that people felt had not solved the
problem yet
so i agreed to be a member of this group
i will tell you that i am
a neutral
that's the way i earn my living
so i work equally for the people who are
paying child support and for the people
who are receiving child support
if at any time i show a bias toward one
of those parents or the other
i have failed to do my job so
i have to be able to look at these
issues help people reach agreement
but not take a position
that
favors one client or the other
i will tell you i have worked with
hundreds of families resolving this
issue
and i have never
encountered a family that was not
willing to
stay at the table and work at this that
has not been able to resolve child
support
what that means is
what this i think that the legislature
in new hampshire has done an excellent
job of providing people like me
mediators who work with families trying
to resolve the issue
as well as
judges
in those
minority of cases that are forced to
make decisions because parents cannot
agree
the law that you have in place now
allows me to do my job
it gives me the tools i need to have
these people make decisions and settle
these cases themselves
and what i will say about i would say
the majority of my cases involve
approximately equal parenting schedules
because in the law it says that children
do best when each parent has
a meaningful continuing contact the
child has that with each parent it's
encouraged that each parent spend as
much time as possible so parents agree
to that in the majority of cases that i
work on
but at the same time what they agree to
in terms of child support varies
depending on the specific circumstances
in each case
so
let's bring common sense into this if we
have one parent who earns twenty
thousand dollars a month and another
parent who earns two thousand dollars a
month
and i've i've passed out
a child support guidelines worksheet
that i
helped a family complete a week ago
in that case
one parent earned 160 000 a year the
other parent earned 30 000 a year
they had five children
the guideline said i believe it's thirty
three hundred and two dollars
in that case the higher earner was the
father they had an equal parenting
schedule and the father said of course
i'm gonna pay the guideline amount
of child support just look at my income
and reduce my income by that 3 300
and add it to the to the mom's income
and you can see i still have a huge
disparity in income i can support the
children
fine on my end so
what the law is is we're trying to we
have to keep the focus on the welfare of
the children because what's good for the
children is good for the parents
i'm a parent of five children i don't
know how many of you have children
but i learned a long time ago that a
parent can only be as happy as their
unhappiest child
so
that is that is what it is and that's
what i try to keep
my clients focus on i don't care what
you agree to it has to make sense
to you
so in equal parenting cases if you have
two parents who are in similar incomes
and have the children a similar amount
of time in a case like that most parents
agree to no child support
we have equal income and we have equal
expenses we have the kids an equal
amount of time it's common sense
so they they put in in these agreements
that are presented to the court no child
support in a case like that i have never
had a judge fail to sign that order okay
or ever question it
if you have two people with this example
i just gave you they agree to guideline
support it's common sense
this is not something that's
controversial
where you get to the to the area and
then there's everything in between i
have many clients that don't agree to
guidelines
but they agree to something just less
than the guidelines
so uh representative yokela you asked a
lot of good questions and i think one of
them was what do you do in a case when
it's 61
right and the the answer is that you use
judgment and common sense is the
guidelines right well maybe what we're
doing is putting bumpers in the bowling
alley with this uh senate bill 431
the high end is guidelines amount the
low end
is zero
but in k but in cases we have net the
difference right we put that lower that
lower bumper there that has never
existed before and actually this net the
distance difference idea has never been
articulated in law before
so that is what we're doing we're
providing it's you guys have given us
the tools we have the tools if you had a
carpenter come to your house and he
butchered the job are you going to blame
the hammer no you're going to blame the
person who's using the hammer we have
the tools
the we don't want to throw out right now
there was an article in the concord
monitor
several months ago that talked about the
data for new hampshire children we rank
second in the country on the metrics
associated with child well-being
that's because of what this body has
done
to put the focus on children we only
have seven i say only it's too much
seven percent of our children in this
state
live below the poverty line the national
average is
that's a 143 percent
more than what we have accomplished in
this state
so this is not the problems that people
are talking about here and the people
who testify against this bill are
well-meaning people they're not bad
people they may have had a bad
experience and they look at these laws
through the prism of that experience
i'm telling you
i'm looking at this from a neutral
standpoint i spent i can't tell you how
many hours i spent
working with this group to try to come
up with this solution i think it solves
the problem without overstepping and
throwing out the baby with the bath
water and hurting harming children uh in
the long run we don't want to be in a
position five or ten years from now
where the concord monitor is writing an
article about how we've fallen from
second
to twenty-seventh okay that's it i get a
handful of other people that want to
testify are there any questions
representative yocala
thank you thank you for uh taking the
question
um
it seems like there is um
a goal of
equaling or
um
reducing the difference between
incomes for um
more uh so that they
have the
e more equal standard of living at each
um
uh
household instead of that each parent
has
the ability to pay for
the um
their share of the
um response
their parental support obligation
um
can you
can you speak a little bit towards um
that um
that uh question sure certainly
so i think i think there's again what i
see in my office is there is a general
rejection of the idea that any amount of
child support is going to flip incomes
so that the person who earns more pays
so much child support that now they're
earning less after child support is paid
that's again common sense that's
something that every client understands
i've never had anybody propose anything
like that right and we're not talking
about
of course
the the goal is so that children can
have a similar experience in both
households because
it is in the current law which i think
is good law
there is a recognition that children do
best if they don't view one parent as
the parent who is able to support them
and the other parent as the parent who
is incapable of providing that support
in their household so they go to one
house and they live in opulence and they
can afford to do all these things they
go to the other house they don't have
their own bed they're sleeping on the
couch
there aren't enough bedrooms if you have
teenage boys and girls you need a
three-bedroom place or
so so there are there are realities
the financial affidavit again talking
about common sense the financial
affidavit on page one lists the income
on page three
every client every parent that goes in
front of the files a petition with the
court has to show what their reasonable
expenses are when they're filing a joint
petition each party has to agree that
what's on the other party's financial
affidavit is reasonable
so if one person is earning twenty five
hundred dollars a month working full
time and on page three reasonable
expenses are thirty five hundred dollars
a month
that is not sustainable a thousand
dollar a month deficit so if the other
party has the surplus has the income
to supplement the first party's income
the state
acknowledges that that person since they
have the children and they are the other
parent
is more appropriate to be providing that
support than the state would be so so in
effect it isn't to equalize the incomes
it's for one parent if necessary to
provide enough income to the other
parent so that they can provide again a
similar
lifestyle not the same vacation to
hawaii
but a similar experience for the kids in
each home
does that answer your question
do you have a follow-up
um
i i rather move on to
representative belanger thank you madam
chair and thank you uh tony yeah for
being here today i appreciate your
testimony
i am by no means an expert in child
support i'm a child of child support and
i don't necessarily agree with it
however my question
is i don't quite understand so if a
parent on scenario two parent a is gross
grossing we're talking about this is
your salary your salary is sixty five
thousand dollars correct we're not
talking about after taxes
we're talking about in scenario two one
parent earn 65 000 the other parent
earned 60 000 correct and again we're
talking about gross per year yep correct
before taxes yep
may i continue madam chair please do
we're running out of time so assuming
that
this parent is uh obligated to pay 10
000.92 based on your 841 dollar per
month calculation
is that is that correct no it's not
correct because in that scenario the
person that would be paying child
support only earns 52
of the combined income so in that case
net the difference would be the presumed
amount or would be the the amount that
would be allowed so where you look at
the highlights i'm sorry i didn't
explain this chart
so if you look at the scenarios here
there are five scenarios
in the first two scenarios the incomes
the income of the higher earning parent
is less than 60 percent of the total
income that's why in our bill in 431 it
would say that net the difference is an
appropriate
option
so rather than the eight
rather than the 841 dollars we're saying
it would be appropriate for that higher
earning parent to pay only seventeen
dollars a month
and then if you look at this uh if you
go over to the right of that seventeen
dollars it shows what the parents income
would be after paying support and after
receiving support
so in that scenario the person paying
child support instead of fifty four
hundred sixteen dollars they have fifty
four hundred the other parent instead of
five thousand has five thousand
seventeen dollars the difference in
incomes are shown in that far right
column
so if you look at the last three
scenarios those are scenarios where the
higher earning parent actually earns
more than 60 percent of the combined
gross monthly income which is more than
one and a half times the lower earning
parent so in those cases we're saying
the guideline amount would not be
inappropriate it still would be the
presumed amount however the parties can
agree to deviate which they do every day
in my office or a judge can look at the
factors and say you know what guidelines
maybe isn't appropriate in this case
because of these factors and order
something less than the guidelines
so i appreciate your question because
yes you're right if we were to use the
guidelines what we concluded doing our
analysis is if the guidelines were
ordered in that case that probably would
not be fair
so i agree with you 100 percent
thank you for that and thank you madam
chair i'm also thank you
you have a question representative
yokola
so in in um
scenario two
you
you agree that right now
under the current guidelines it is
unfair
no because under the current guidelines
the guidelines
there the guide there's a guideline
amount and then there are
many many reasons
why a judge that the judge can factor in
when deciding that the guidelines would
not be fair so the guidelines would not
be ordered in a case
in that in this case so this idea and
i've heard this testimony before that if
one parent earns one dollar more than
the other parent they're going to be
ordered to pay the guidelines that is
untrue that has never happened to my
knowledge and it has never happened in
my office in hundreds of cases i will
tell you that
so i feel like that
i'm happy to answer your question
one more i still have three more
speakers
i understand
but this this is the public hearing and
we need that i understand that there are
three other people that may have answers
for you also
that's
possible but um
do you do you um
agree that in
the supreme court's ruling in silva v
silva says that a deviation is not
allowed for um
the fact that it is equal um
that
that parents have equal parenting time
and so that is not even though currently
it's not
in the law it says that it's not the
sole reason that the the the court has
ruled that to be not a reason
absolutely not that is a
misunderstanding of the silva
uh ruling
the supreme court the lower court in
that case found that there was
justification for a deviation from the
guidelines based on the fact that the
obligor the person paying child support
had shown
that there was a reduction in fixed
costs
to the obligate or the person receiving
child supports fixed costs
the judge in the lower court went on to
articulate
what those fixed cost reductions were
and every one of the fixed costs that
they articulated in the law in the in
the ruling was not a fixed cost but
rather a variable cost so what the
higher court did what the supreme court
said was
when the lower court looked at this
issue
they could have it would have been
possible if the reduction in fixed costs
were actually fixed costs that were
reduced
that it would have been uh justified a
deviation it could have justified a
deviation from the guidelines but the
lower court didn't say that the lower
court said it reduced fixed expenses and
then used as examples of those fixed
expenses several variable expenses in
fact
what they listed were in the definition
of variable expenses
in the law
so the lower court clearly made a
mistake the higher court had nothing
else to do but to rule that the lower
court had made and throw it back to the
lower court and say if you want to do a
deviation based on a change in fixed
expenses then show us
which fixed expenses were actually
reduced so that's what it was about it
wasn't saying that you cannot
uh do a deviation from the guidelines
that's a misunderstanding of that ruling
are you all set
thank you very much you're very welcome
thank you up next is lisa
uh
oh katowski is that correct
and attorney susan bursham who's asked
for five minutes
so who's going to be speaking i will be
okay thank you thank you
and you are
good morning my name is
for the record my name is lisa
dekatowski
and i am the bureau chief with the
bureau of child support services on
behalf of the department of health and
human services
and i'm susan brisson i'm the chief
staff attorney for child support
thank you for the opportunity to speak
um and good morning to everyone
the department of health and human
services through the bureau of child
support
program administers the child support
program for the
on behalf of the title four dates
social security act
and we're really here today to just
provide the committee with some
information
to ensure that you are aware that the
department of health and human services
as required by statute is currently
going through a guidelines review year
this year and we do anticipate that the
review will
yield some very helpful
and recommendations
for the legislature to consider
in regards to the child support
guidelines
certainly the review considers the
economic data of the cost of raising
children and includes an analysis of
case data
on the application of and the deviations
from the current child support
guidelines
and will
provide recommendations and findings and
an analysis
of current
data available to us for the purposes of
the quadrennial review
the report is anticipated to be
completed by the end of this calendar
year as of december 31st
of 2022
and again we just want the committee to
be aware that we do anticipate that this
review report of our current child
support guidelines and the data that is
available to us will hopefully yield to
some helpful recommendations
are there any questions
representative ocala
hi thank you um
uh
have
you
um
are you aware of the 2018 guideline
review uh
and the recommendations that it proposed
um
i guess that would be my first question
yes
um
are you a par um i guess
are you a part of the or you know of the
current workings of the
current um review and um if there is
um
like conflicts or differences um that
you have identified thus far between
what your current review is and the um
in the the 2018 study
thank you for that question so the
review is in its infancy stages of data
collection we have contracted with a
vendor who commenced
the analysis that they will complete
this year as of january 1st of this year
so we are in the preliminary stages of
data collection um and review and
analysis
with our vendor that's been contracted
so what their recommendations or
findings may be at this point in
comparison to the 2018 guidelines review
report is yet to be
yet to be seen follow up
absolutely thank you um so you have no
reason to believe that they wouldn't
um come up with the exact same
recommendations because we haven't
followed those 2018 guideline
recommendations i don't know what their
recommendation is exactly representative
at this point thank you
representative
thank you madam chair i just wanted to
know when you filled out your pink card
are you did you fill it out in in
neutral that you're just here to answer
questions or provide information just to
provide information thank you that's all
i want to know thank you thank you
there any further questions
representative ocala
thank you um for this study how much did
we are we contracted to pay for this
study with the
the new
people the total contracted amount with
the um new vendor i believe is
um bear with me one second
approximately a hundred and thirty six
thousand
thank you
elsa
any further questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
up next is mary krueger from new
hampshire legal assistance
she has written testimony she supports
the bill and she's asked for five
minutes
thank you
my name is mary krueger i'm a staff
attorney with new hampshire legal
assistance we're a statewide non-profit
law firm we represent low-income and
older
granite staters in
a wide variety of civil legal issues
mainly surrounding poverty
law
we operate a domestic violence advocacy
project i'm an attorney on that project
we represent
victims and survivors of domestic
violence sexual assault and stalking in
protection order cases and family law
cases
we
prioritize cases that are high lethality
cases and those are cases where
the violence is severe and continuing
and so we see some of the the worst
cases
that you can imagine going through our
family courts
in new
hampshire
i've been doing this since 2006.
i was part of the alimony working group
and we were really looking out for the
interests of domestic violence survivors
if there's going to be any law change to
child support that can have a huge
impact it can also have a huge impact on
people living in poverty
children in poverty
and we're very concerned
when we see changes
being made to policy around child
support in our state
because we want to ensure that children
more children don't go into poverty new
hampshire does
quite well
and is second um in the nation in terms
of the lowest poverty rate um and we'd
like to to see it stay that way this
bill here really just focuses in on one
aspect
of the current law
that would address equal and
approximately equal parenting schedules
it still presumes that the guideline
amount is the amount of child support
and we think that that is an important
policy to maintain because domestic
violence abusers use coercive control
in the form of violence and financial
control in addition to emotional and
psychological control the financial
component can be used as a way to keep a
victim in the relationship
oftentimes abusers are the higher
earners
oftentimes abused victims aren't allowed
to work or only allowed to work very low
wage jobs
if we have a situation where an abuser
is incentivized to decide to fight over
parenting time
an otherwise uninvolved abusive parent
may decide to do that if they see that
there's an incentive to lower their
child support obligation
with this change it just provides more
precise parameters keeping the best
interest of the children
in mind
so that the courts we litigate a number
of cases so
i'd like to be able to mediate probably
50 percent of my cases do settle
um often when i have a good attorney on
the other side we can be the reasonable
people to help
move things along but we litigate
probably 50 percent of our family law
cases
and so
when we look at this law i'm looking at
is how a judge is going to apply it
and the judge is going to keep front and
center
the best interest of the children
and to look at the lower earning parent
to make sure that that per parent can
continue to meet the cost of child
rearing in a similar or approximately
equal style as to that of the other
parent and that those are the policies
that would be in place that a judge
would have to apply
in order to decide if they're going to
go to the next step of adjusting a child
support
when the parties don't agree and we
believe that that's a strong an
important policy to preserve
especially for children who have been
suffering in domestic violence homes
this also is protective of low-income
people because we have those bumpers in
the bowling alley as
tony mentioned where
if the court does decide to
adjust it it's in a fair way where
people are earning similar incomes and
we think we often have parents who are
both low income and that that's a fair
way to allocate
if there is an equal or approximately
equal
parenting schedule and we do have cases
that that have those um schedules um we
have two low-income parents that the
difference could be a really good tool
for a court to use in order to have a
fair
amount of support so the parents can
share the income across the household
so thank you very much
are there any questions
representative yokela
thank you and thank you for taking the
question um
there were more uh
recommendations
than just addressing the um the equal
and shared parenting time
uh
question inside of the 2018 study
um
is there a reason that
maybe the
the working group did not
broach any of the other suggestions that
were made in that study
we
yes we were not looking at broad policy
change for the child support law we were
looking at this very narrow special
circumstance that's current currently in
the law
regarding equal or approximately legal
parenting time
mainly that is because
i've been in and out of this legislature
for a number of years
along with honey hastings sitting on
some committees
this is an issue that keeps coming up
about the equal or approximately equal
parenting time and how to better guide
courts
in making decisions around that given
that more families are you know doing
equal and approximately equal parenting
time so it's been an issue in front of
this committee many times um and that's
something that we really felt that we
could really devote the time and energy
and brain power to figuring out so that
was exactly what we had
committed to doing um to senator carson
last year
do you have a follow-up
okay are there any further questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
up next is michael
dinar
to speak in opposition to the bill he's
asked for 10 minutes i'm gonna ask you
to bring it down to five thank you
and my name is michael the last name is
pronounced dinan sorry like dinan or
take out is what the job scientists came
up with after years of research
um i'm uh
a father of two lovely young ladies i'm
part from rockingham county i'm just a
father who's been living this uh the
current guidelines uh since 2018 um i've
spoken on this matter a few times and
have uh actually had reached out to the
working group several times as well and
have spoken with tony machamolo and
reached out to honey hastings aries
aaron jazzy as well i'm here today just
to talk about sp 431 and the the um
devastating nature of our current
guidelines which i think sp 431 would
turn into legislatures so
since silva v silva i think we're all
aware of it it hasn't mentioned very
much but this is the reality every uh
judge is by precedent case law follows
silva v silva there are rarely
exceptions the mentions of mediation
which is great and would be wonderful if
most parents could qualify for mediation
and work through that process but most
cannot because of there were words like
agreement mediation
most of them end up in court most of
them end up having child support laws
and guidelines established by
individual family courts and judges and
since 2018 and this is reality it's my
reality and for most every other parent
they actually
um established because of silly silva
that the two criteria were mentioned one
is uh reduction of fixed cost
and also equal or approximately equal
parenting time are not justifications by
themselves for a deviation from
guidelines so what that means is
whether a hiring parent and lowering
parent
have 50 50 parenting time i have my
children over 55 of the time
it does not matter the lower earner
receives all the funds available i think
everyone would agree in this group uh
everyone that spoke that you know we
know parenting is best for 50 of the
time that parents children do best with
both of their parents
because of that that's that is the the
truth and in my case very much but what
happens is all the funds go just to one
household the lower earner and it was
stated previously and i'll say it again
that means one dollar less than the
higher earner so what would i actually
if i could pass out some of the uh
reference material thank you
um
and this it's in this you get a chance a
lot better than that's
well there's not enough copies for it i
think i have eight copies
yeah there's more than
i had one that got chewed by her
guys
and i'll try and hit the high points and
do this quickly
so what that means is and i've
provided some of the calculations um and
this has been since 2018 of course so if
the lower order makes a dollar or just
one dollar less all of those funds go to
the lower earner uh this is reality this
is not something that's conjecture or
subjective as a lot of the words you
heard and i want to talk about 431 in a
second but this is because of silvery
silva what actually would happen with
431 it was take that and make it law so
it wouldn't actually even be precedent
anymore it would make it law and the
very important parts of this that are so
critical of this
are how it actually does that so
the only relief that would be provided
and i think everyone agrees and it i
noted in here the study that was done by
the by the carsey school the dartmouth
study also the national parenting group
that gave the state of new hampshire an
f
we pay the third highest amount in the
country we are we pay a thousand dollars
more than the average so you have all
these available studies the previous
study that was done uh by the that was
sanctioned as similar to the study
that's coming up um at the end of this
year which is another study this has
been this has been the previous attempts
at this were bill 228 and 161 both of
them had suffered the same fate this
repeating the same thing over and over
again expecting a different result is
kind of that definition of crazy
but in this case we have actually but
it's been identified that we are the
third highest amount pay a thousand
dollars more but what's really happening
is all those funds go to one household
so we talk about the higher earner
versus the lower earner and our ability
to parent effectively we all agree that
50 is the way to to establish parenting
time but what happens is all of the
funds
go to the lower earning parent that
means that any decisions and all these
decisions that came in here which 431
proposes to turn over to the judge are
already burning courts i have to go to
court on a regular basis to try and
advocate for my family for my two
daughters but what it would do is take
everything that we talk about that
currently are decided by the lower
parent our current guidelines 431 would
do the same
all the decisions of how that those
funds are spent could be brought into
court so anytime there's a disagreement
there were some interesting testimony by
jay markle who's i think uh well known
to this this
group as well it talked about
it says it right here vacations uh
entertainment electronics everything
that would be subject to the courts so
that means every time there's a
disagreement it can be brought into
court we keep talking about mediation
that's for
certain few people that can actually
qualify to go to mediation that they're
already in agreement
if people are getting divorced and
they're separated and their families are
split there's usually more disagreement
than agreement so in most cases they are
going to court and this would actually
allow
anytime there's a disagreement a
disparity between two households you
could take that to court the higher or
the lower i jokingly say in my testimony
that qualified as popcorn if one family
gets popcorn one parrot pays for popcorn
the other parent has to pay for popcorn
is there butter on it is there a
goldfish at one house the other house
qualifies for that that's entertainment
television everything falls into this
but that's what this would do
it's intended to provide relief i think
we all agree that any of these laws that
are being considered are intended to
provide relief to the current issue of
silva v silva because of the strict
language that all judges have to follow
not mediators judges and everything that
431 would end up in court
so what 431 it proposes those people
between 50 percent and 60
that means that
the higher versus the low winner has to
be within that 50 percent
bracket that 10
of the actual amount of cases going
through
what that means is
if you're already you have to be that 50
to be the higher earner we all agree 50
versus 50 you have to be 51 percent and
that only goes up to 60
if you go through and you look at my
calculations and i want to be very clear
about what tony machamolo from the
mediation group from the working group
had proposed
actually don't show
after taxes
i have to pay the funds and most higher
earners have to pay
after taxes
then what the his calculations do not
show as well and i have these his
calculations right here is that the
lower earner is paying does not have to
pay taxes on what is received so any of
these calculations provide a
very biased uh
assessment of of current guidelines so
the relief would only be provided up to
60 percent what do we really have
disparity and where this kind of the the
problem is for most parents is that the
higher earner can't make any decisions
can't make any decisions just to the use
of those funds there is no agreement
that's why they're in court in the first
place judges have to follow sylvie silva
it has not been changed there's been no
lower court it is still precedent for
all all parents so a couple quick points
and i'd love to answer some questions
is that the subjective nature i think
everyone agrees we want bumpers that was
an analogy that was used by two of the
folks that spoke before me we're looking
for guidelines
something that we can all hang our hat
on that judges can hang their hat on
what 431 would do would make it the wild
west every time there is a dis
disagreement on the disparity between
households it would allow that to be
heard in court per this law
it allows
the
lower earner
the same thing that we have now they
will have all the funds there's no
relief to sylvie silva and it actually
worsens it i want to make a very good
point about this because this is what
was discussed before
and then this is on um
section 9
roman numeral 9
and i want to be very clear about this
because this is law and this is what
people reference laws not mediation
groups not agreements not conjecture and
and happy feelings that people want to
talk about we are dealing with a real
reality
and this is what's so important if the
net difference
method does not meet rsa458 c colon five
dash lowercase a roman numeral two
criteria the court may order the child
support guidelines amount or
another amount that does meet the
criteria at rsa450 458 c colon five what
that means is that it allows the the
judge it allows the courts to be raising
our children it does not allow the
parents to make any decisions i cannot
and any parent the higher earner sense
this
is in a dis
indigent state there's no ability for me
to allocate funds for for secondary
education for savings
all of the funds and this is the reality
not conjecture go to the lowering parent
what 458c would do
is make everything
subject to that subjective it allows the
judge and again has to go to court our
court's already overburdened they're
already overwhelmed with these things
these cases go on and on and in my case
in particular it it which is very
relevant to this
every one of my orders says silva v
silva because of silverbee silva
there is no relief no judge has the
ability doesn't have the the tools they
don't have the tools to do the right
thing they have to follow it yes if it's
a mediation if people are fortunate
enough to qualify for mediation but what
458c would do is turn everything into
conjecture subjective and it i think the
worst part about this
is that everyone stating that 50 50
parenting time is equal but they're not
willing to let that be the case with
with the parents and i want to be very
clear
in the current silverbee silva and what
458c would propose
is that the higher earner ends up with
inadequate amount of funds and i know it
sounds bizarre and i share my
calculations with you there as well
the higher earner cannot pay for
anything has no funds left
parents living in in the fire barn
because they're they're firemen and they
have to pay all their funds the higher
having to children that have to live in
their vehicles with them it is happening
because the higher owner has no funds i
don't want to be clear about this it
actually promotes
the lower earner from not having to work
it promotes
division of families because the lower
earner with every lawyer and everyone as
we are all discussing right now is very
aware of silva v silva it'll it promotes
the lower earner to actually say well i
can do my calculations and this is what
i'll be funds will be available to me it
actually promotes
this union of families and there's a lot
of talk and mention of you know
the abusers that are there are are using
these funds to somehow control the the
lower earner uh i want to be very clear
a parenting plan is established in
advance of any uso uniform support order
that comes from the judge the parenting
plan is based on the two affidavits the
parenting plan whether the parenting
time is established far in advance and
separately from the actual
uniform support order which is the
financial amount that's ordered by by
the court that's done in advance they do
not relate they do not intertwine
there's no way for one to
it affect the other but what really is
is happening it's in what i had handed
out
is we pay the third highest amount there
was mention of title 4d
uh people say that this somehow will
affect the lower earner what
there's other laws as we all know that
are being considered this time
none of them would actually reduce the
amount of funds paid they would actually
just
change how they are allocated and
currently i think we all agree
that
funds due to silvery silva go to the
lower earner that's the law that is what
we're dealing with and i just want to
add the last thing is that if you read
through these things and i just want to
hit some of the highlights of them
because this is where the kind of
and i'll say it absurdity of this this
431 comes into
if you read vacation summer care
extracurricular activities
travel entertainment vacations and
people can translate vacations however
they like and the question was asked
february vacations summer vacations if
one family does go to winnipesaukee the
other family per 458c and it's very
clear can actually pursue the same thing
in that disparity and then it all comes
down to roman numeral nine the court may
order child support guidelines amount or
another amount so this again everything
goes back to court the other laws that
are out there or legislation that's
being proposed actually provides solid
guidelines that the judge
that all participants can follow it
doesn't make it this kind of wild west
that that 458 with its good intentions
still still does so and i wanted to
mention something you know when the the
working group came up with this there
was a question as to why it didn't
follow the car seat study why it didn't
fall the national averages and also why
didn't why weren't you know parents
allowed to participate uh there's a bill
woodbury who's from the new hampshire
bar association he's on the on the the
parent working group but i had asked all
the individuals in advance of this
outcome to participate and i was not
even responded to
and it's kind of a bizarre closed
you know creation that was
devised by people that are not really
living this day to day the mediator
doesn't see what really goes on in court
uh some of the the the discussion was
based on things that were from the 80s
not from what we're dealing with today
so
i appreciate everyone hearing me out and
it's obviously a very sensitive subject
because many parents higher earners
mothers and fathers are are living this
every day so thank you for your time are
there any questions
representative ocala thank you um and
thank you for mentioning the parenting
time because that was the question that
i forgot that the the parenting time is
actually decided elsewhere and has um
and so my question is um
is uh
does the
do you believe that the um
that the money
um
aspect should
flow directly from
what um
the parenting
time was decided to be in the best
interest of the child so the money
required to be able to support that
parenting time should uh
flow directly from that that uh decision
so
the the problem with current guidelines
for f8c equal or approximately equal
parenting time is not grounds for
deviation by itself so
if there is 50 50 parenting time which
everyone agrees is the norm yes that
should so currently 100 of all funds
available go to the lower earner
of course if they're with me 50 of time
the time i'm going to have those
expenses and everyone's right when you
have two different households that's
there are more expenses than just having
the one the sum of the parts is greater
than the than the thing itself so
yes i do
thank you
um can i follow up or kind of a nuke um
um
for the
the discussion uh regarding these
variable expenses
um
it is your understanding in the reading
of this that um you know
if people do not agree
ahead of time on what these who should
be paying for these variable expenses
and you may be able to go to court and
argue that you need a deviation from the
normal guidelines because
the of you know whatever these variable
expenses are um
not covered under the normal uh
the normal guidelines that is correct so
this would solidify turn silva v silva
into law and what that does is still
only for the 50 to 60 would provide
relief for anyone that's over
um that 50 60 50 to 60
area anyone that's only 10
so everyone else would actually be still
have the lower earner receiving all the
funds available and in addition to that
the lower earner could then go and say
well uh popcorn vacations flat-screen tv
in one home
driver's licenses car insurance things
that are supposed to be the parent's
decision not the court's decision and
again agreement if there is disagreement
people have different parenting styles
people have different uh ways they like
to raise their children not allowing
them to have devices not allowing them
to watch tv all day
none of that would be allowed with with
431 it would turn all of that over the
courts the courts would be parenting
our children because everyone would go
to the courts immediately they could say
entertainment electronics a television
those things are all conjecture
subjective
we're looking for something that
actually provides real guidelines that
puts us in line with the rest of the
federal standards that puts us in line
with the
agreed to which is 50
parenting time is best for children this
would this would turn into the wild west
and it would
further send and i say it in my my
written testimony
these children are in the abyss right
now and parents have to spend all their
time if they have any or have any money
available to to keep advocating for
their children because this is about the
children not about some money factor but
in most of these cases the higher has no
funds available so thank you
are there any further questions
it's seeing none thank you very much
thank you so i'm going to close the
public hearing on senate bill 431
before we start the next bell first i
want to apologize for running so late
and keeping people waiting
secondly not to embarrass anyone or
anything but if i could ask miss sanchez
to just introduce herself briefly to the
committee i saw her come in
miss sanchez is going to be
filling the shoes of moira o'neil in the
office of the child advocate
so welcome to children and family law
we'll see a lot of you i'm sure
thank you
okay now i'm going to open the public
hearing on sb 458
if you just hand it they'll hand it down
and i'm going to call up senator gary
daniels to speak in the support of the
bill with reservations
oh and by the way the new bill that was
handed out for 458 that was because
there was no fiscal note attached to the
other one so this one they
they wanted they wanted to put in the
significant impact
thank you senator
good morning madam chair member of the
committee for the record my name is gary
daniels i'm a state senator from
district 11 representing the towns of
wilton milford amherst and merrimack
also the prime sponsor of senate bill
when we passed the budget
last year house bill 2 there was a
section of that that created a study
committee to talk about the closure of
the cindernew center and there were five
people appointed to that two members of
this committee uh including myself
and i i chaired that committee
what you have before you today
uh is not what came out
of of that thing and that's why i'm
testifying in support because i know
something has to be done but with
reservations because what we ended up
coming
out with is an initial report um
what was changed in in the senate with
the amendment that you have
before you
uh there were three primary things that
we were directed through through house
bill two number one is that
uh
we're looking looking for
a residential type field that was the
that was the
um feedback that came back from those
people that appeared before the study
committee they wanted a residential feel
inside and outside
not an institutional look
secondly
that the closure date was march
was march 1st 2023
aggressive
yes but you know i think the majority of
us felt that it would it was doable and
it put out an incentive
there to
not let the thing
be delayed
uh and third thirdly the the size of the
facility
i needed to
accommodate 18 beds and that's because
not because you were going to have 18
people there but
because they need to be separated by
agenda they needed to be second rated by
needs
and
and others so it was just necessary to
have that that
type of accommodation
uh i have sent a link to each of your
email
that will give you the the information
from the
study committee report including the
final one i will say that there's quite
a lot there so
you can use up your weekend uh on that
uh
and uh
so there in the in the interim since
then uh they've come in with a new
amendment
which
proposes building a
a new facility on yet
uh
undesignated state land
uh there's been talk about making the
facility smaller than 18.
uh beds
there's also been a lot of talk about
how
using residential
and i'm talking more private residential
because
i think we figured with the march date
that we had
you didn't have time to build a new
facility
so taking what was existing out there
now
uh and accommodating
uh that
we've heard a lot of feedback about how
a lot of abuse happens
in
private
uh residential um
i guess i would counter that by saying
we have a hundred million dollars worth
of suits and counting
that came out of sununu
and that was under state control
so one of the things that kind of raises
raises a question in my mind is that are
we giving hhs so much responsibility
and we know that they have loads of of
people
uh uh vacant positions are we putting so
much on that department that they
haven't got the ability to oversee
uh the things that need to be done such
that these things are happening
uh and maybe
going within the direction of a private
it allows you have personnel to take
care of that still going to be on the
hhs oversight you know we want we want
to control so they're going to have to
control uh uh if they want to contract
with us they're going to have to go
according to the contract that's set up
you hear about non-disclosure
acts there's no reason why something
like that can't be built into a contract
so that
when you're you're contracting with a
private concern that they know
if the state comes in and says we want
to inspected this we want to investigate
this
it's a it's a done deal they can't back
out of it now i'll
get toward closing to say that
hhs contracts all the time
with private
concerns
i mean many many many programs because
we don't do it all as a state we go out
and we take those organizations and
those agencies that can do that and they
specialize in that and so this is not
setting anything precedence
by by going
going in this direction
um
we do believe that
uh
we ought to be uh getting out of sununu
as quickly as possible
and that's why you know i i tend to
uh prefer the march first date i know
that there was some consternation in
there because we said that uh if the uh
facility isn't built and ready to take
the um
the the youth by
uh march first that uh
the bill
uh had said the original one had said we
would put them out of state i would have
no objection if you wanted to leave them
at sununu until it's done but i mean the
the way that this was amended in the
senate uh it now actually
allows you to drag it out another two
years
and i i think that's just way way too
long uh hhs has a program that they're
ready to put in
in place and the sooner we can get that
going i think the better it is for all
of us
thank you madam chair
are there any questions for the senator
representative belanger
thank you madam chair thank you senator
for being here and thank you for your
testimony just to clarify
having been on the commission
what were the three recommendations that
came out of that commission
uh three three recommendations were one
of them to use the uh the private
residential
secondly to build a new facility
somewhere on state land which would
require at least 10 acres and thirdly to
modify sununu center to make it smaller
thank you i just wanted that
clarification representative yokela
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um so you you said you supported it with
reservations and it seemed from your
testimony that your major observation is
that they could drag it out for two
years is that correct my understanding
or is there is there more things that
you um
are concerned about in the current
language that's one of the reservations
the the other reservations i i have are
i don't know that we need to spend the
money to build a new facility i mean the
senate did did take out the 15 million
dollar appropriation on that because
frankly we we ran out of time and didn't
didn't have the time to to come to a
final conclusion on doing doing that um
but thirdly i think some some um
investigation needs to to
be had to determine whether or not
uh
this should be something that is
directly overseen
by hhs uh with
the track record we had with sununu and
um make sure we don't overload
our
staff and the um
the ability to to access
uh other private concerns that
that do these things all the time so i
think there are other options that that
are out there rather than go in the
direction that we did
are there any further questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
up next is rebecca ross and john
williams
to speak in support of the bill and they
need 10 minutes
madam chair and members of the house
children and family law committee for
the record my name is john williams i am
the director of legislative affairs for
the new hampshire department of health
human services
wow that was quick
i can talk fast but not that fast and
with me today is good morning rebecca
ross director of the bureau for
children's behavioral health and
director ribsum from dcyf is unable to
attend today so we're here on his behalf
as well
so chairman rice i wanted to thank you
up front as you being a co-sponsor for
the bill along with senator daniels
and i think it's helpful just for
document control uh to make sure that
everybody does have the um one as passed
by the
senate it will have three amendments and
the last of the amendments are 1272 s
fantastic so the um bill if i could just
give a very high level less than a
minute or two walk through the
legislation because i did work with the
senate leadership as well as well as uh
mr director ripson on the drafting of
the legislation um that section one uh
does articulate the building of the new
secured facility i do understand
starting on page one between lines three
and five that we certainly want to honor
the perspective of the sponsors for the
bill particularly around serving the 12
youths that is the goal and the
objective and i would um do have
language prepared that i believe
represent rice has been provided to you
if there's not enough time because of
you having to get this bill
completed before the 14th the deadline
for second committee bills certainly
would continue working with you moving
forward as well on making those
adjustments it has to be out of
committee today because we didn't plan
on
right because it has to be done before
next week
that was my clear understanding that you
had to exec out on the bill today so
that was um given the timing i do have
copies of the amendment at your
direction that i could share uh with
your committee um and if ms ross if you
could help me with that
thank you so much
and as miss ross is
circulating uh attorney ross circulating
that
um the key components here on the
amendment is to identify the the goal
here is to serve an average of 12 youths
at the facility we do need as senator
daniels pointed out sufficient space and
flexibility to be able to
appropriately
separate the children on occasion
by gender age excuse me one second can
everybody please silence their phones i
keep hearing phones going up and it's
just very disrespectful to the people
speaking thank
you may continue i'm sorry thank you so
we would suggest for your consideration
to substitute in the sentence that is
found
uh between lines three and five of the
bill as it passed by the senate to
include the language you'll see that the
highlighted language in the draft that
was provided to you is the additional
language to clarify that we're seeking
to
serve an average of 12 youth uh striking
the word 18 beds continuing on with an
additional sentence that you'll see that
says in order to accommodate for the
individual needs of youth including
gender diverse diverse clinical needs
emergency separation of youth for safety
and security and the opportunity to
provide space for crisis stabilization
the physical layout may not may have no
more than 18 private
sleeping rooms for youth and we do think
that that clarifies and honors
the
concern regarding
the use of singularly of the 18 beds and
again that's for your consideration and
can certainly address questions
regarding this section before moving on
to other sections or i can keep moving
along does anybody have a question
representative desimone
thank you madam chairman's part right uh
yeah
on the amendment
okay so
um i agree so far but underneath uh the
bolded type it says that the department
shall consult with any prospective
community about the location and
operation of any new 18 bed facility
should that be changed to 12.
and
that actually is in the bills that came
over from the senate um i believe that
our goal here is to pre to preface and
the very introductory section here that
everything following that for any
reference to 18 has to acknowledge the
fact that the it's to serve 12 children
the 18 beds is just to allow the
flexibility to serving those 12 children
thank you
representative belanger thank you madam
chair and uh thank you uh mr williams
and miss ross for being here today and
presenting this testimony in regards to
to this and i do see this in in the bill
so i will address
that
uh
um to representative december's point
the department shall consult with any
prospective community about the location
operation of a new 18 bed facility
um
it brings me
to my point if and and i will pref i'm
just prefacing with the question
if are we we're consulting
a a town or community if they're okay
with
an 18 bed facility coming into their
backyard i can name
what do we have 200 and some odd towns
that will say you know
would you agree that you find that to be
a problem as well
appears john is looking to me um i think
the way it's drafted is that we will do
our best to work with communities
however for state facilities on state
land it's not the same zoning process so
while we'll collaborate i don't think
that automatically means that
each community is going to be able to
say no and we will be left without a
place to site the facility similar to
the way it's working with acquiring
hampstead hospital we're very much
working with hampstead
on that transition but
it will still be a state facility within
the town
are there any for further questions on
this amendment
pardon me
do you have a question i okay yep
representative grossman this is proposed
right this is not an amendment yet i'm
sorry right yeah it's proposed
are there any other questions
all right seeing them please continue
governor rice thank you that then takes
us as you can see section one of the
bill set up as chapter laws and it has
individual roman paragraphs so we've now
covered uh paragraph one paragraph two
um identifies that the department has an
obligation and shall issue a procurement
for a qualified design built architect
on or before august 1st of this year
and the following sentence identifies
that we are looking to as part of that
to complete the project on or before
june 30th of 2024. under existing laws
we know um under hb2 the date for
standing up the facility is march of
2023 we do know the realities of
building and having to do this
appropriately and doing it the right way
that the bill is coming before you for
your consideration to setting up a
design to allowing us to be successful
not only in setting up the facilities
but as you'll see in the next sections
to identify the correct approach in
terms of not only building design but
also the programs and staffing for those
facilities so that quickly takes me
through paragraphs um three of the bill
which sets forth the design requirements
for the building uh representation
simone to your point there is another
reference to the 18 beds in here however
with this amendment that would cover us
because it comes before explaining
exactly
why the 18 beds are there not to fill
them but to give flexibility
moving along to section uh four of the
build these are the program programming
operations and this is really critical
and i think the uh advocates that you'll
hear testifying in support of this bill
are going to identify that these are
components that are really necessary to
appropriately address the youths that
are going to be receiving services
through the facilities you have the
staffing qualification standards you
have evidence-based
practices utilization of uniform
assessments provision of care management
visitation opportunities for family
members educational programming and
staffing integration of clinical
assessments and to our new child
advocate who is here with us real-time
access by the office of child advocate
section uh roman five of the bill uh
talks about standing up at least the
first two provisions of these programs
so that there would be a seamless
transition between the existing facility
which is being closed on march 31st uh
rather march first of 2023 and then the
standing up and opening of the facility
which is slated for june of 2023
currently so um and as set forth in this
bill so the department also has
quarterly reporting requirements and i
will say senator rosenwald had a very
good hand in making sure that she
identified certain particular factors
that she needed to have wanted to have
the legislature you and the house also
reported on and you'll see going to page
three of the bill
that there's outlined um subparagraphs a
through
e that give very detailed data-driven
information in terms of the progress for
standing up the new facility
paragraph number seven would give the
governor the authority to go to fiscal
committee of the joint fiscal committee
for both the senate and the house
members to seeking as needed um a um if
circumstances unforeseen were to arise
the ability to come back before the
legislature without having to file a
bill like this again to go back for your
body to move forward on on the
construction if there is a need to um to
extending the time for building um the
thoughtful approach here and i have to
give credit to senator bradley is that
it it does prevent us from every every
year having to come back here before you
on a bill if there is a need to making
certain adjustments based upon materials
based upon location of facilities based
upon as representative blanchard pointed
out citing um
specifications and communities that
there there could be unforeseen but
we'll make best efforts to accommodate
um these requests which brings me to the
the to to accommodate this request you
have to have an appropriation so if i
could direct your attention to page 3
line 21 you'll see at the very end of
that first sentence on that line it says
the sum of one dollar if you could add a
five followed by a comma and six zeros
that would be particularly helpful
that's 50 million dollars um as senator
daniels pointed out it wasn't the
senate's position to tag the department
with one dollar they knew this was going
to cost something they just needed the
additional time to allow the process to
work out through the house to
identifying what that
amount should be as you'll see from the
fiscal note attached to the bill it's
based upon the commission that was
established in hb2 for the closure
of this new new center and on page 126
of that report you'll see that the
department of administrative services
through uh commissioner arlinghaus
identified at that time while looking at
this
the bricks and mortars piece of this was
estimated at 15 million dollars so
that's where that amount of money was
derived from and you could certainly
reference back to that report on page
126.
except yes
up 15 million if i spoke higher than
that that's only because we had
delusional wishes in the department for
50 million dollars but i think i
hopefully said 15 1 5
followed by six zeros
um you'll see on section uh four of the
bill talking about a repeal those are
specific sections in hb2 with timing for
standing up the facility obviously those
need to be taken care of you don't want
two laws on the same with different
dates so those would repeal the
provisions in hp2 for the standing up at
the facility on march of 2023 and then
the effective day after passage i hope
that was a meaningful walkthrough of the
legislation to give you a full depth of
understanding of what was accomplished
in the senate i think they did a
wonderful job with the bill and we are
here certainly to address questions but
before i do that i want to ask uh um um
director attorney ross if she has
anything to offer
um i don't i'm happy to take any
questions and help explain how this
integrates in with the children's system
of care that we've been working on as
well
okay so before i call on people to take
questions i'm gonna take a little
privilege here and say that i think that
if you're a co-sponsor of a bill and
it's gutted in the senate you should be
able to ask a ton of questions
so i need to figure out how we're going
to fix that because i have a ton of
questions that i can't ask
so
the people that can ask questions
representative grossman
go right ahead
thank you madam chair and thank you both
for coming before us today
i have one question related to what
happens to the youth
on march of 2023
so
the facility is closing
but the new facility is not ready yet
right so where are the youth that are in
the sununu center going in that interim
period
having not been involved in the last
couple conversations we would have to
ensure that they are in a secured
setting um during that transition period
it's required by their court orders and
their detention or commitment status and
we would need a seamless transition that
they are not left without a place and
without supervision during that period
of time
representative yokela
thank you and thank you for taking the
question um
in um
i think it's hb uh 254 we're changing
what um
people can be committed um if
uh
if that law went into effect
um
what would be the current population of
committed individuals
we don't believe that that will have a
substantial impact there are absent
flows through the population throughout
the year and at any given time we don't
we don't think it will have a
substantial impact um and so we would
still need to be able to ensure that at
the highest level of of need we're able
to meet the capacity requirements
follow-up
it's actually a different question but
my my um
the question the um on page 3 line
12-14 it says the governor with the
approval of the fiscal committee
can extend the deadline if the fiscal
committee says no
and says we want the sununu center
closed asap
we're not extending the deadline
um what would the department do
um i think we'd be working very closely
with the attorney general's office and
going to court in every single case
where a judge has ordered that an
individual be securely
confined and either looking to move them
out of state or find an alternative plan
but it it would create a substantial
crisis for those youth that are not
ready to transition out
thank you
representative long
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking the questions uh what the first
question is on uh the fir
the first page uh
line 16 says the
the
you'll be completing the project on or
before june 30th 2024
so that's two years from now
and then you extend another two years if
fiscal committee doesn't uh on page um
on uh
page three line starting on line twelves
unforeseen circumstances provide any
such delay be no more than two years
so that's that's a potent
construction industry in the state of
new hampshire
i'm looking at four years to get this
done that's unacceptable to me
um
and and uh so so
yeah so i i guess i'd need to address
that whenever i said yeah this is what
you're agreeing with so
um i won't i won't ask uh and
uh just one more if i may show it up to
you the uh
the implementation of uh starts
page two line four all the way down the
implementation with with while children
remain at the current facility
uh by march 1st of 2023
how do you see that how do you see that
working
i mean it seems like we're we're
doing something we've been doing forever
uh then now we're gonna change that
um so that when the other facility's
ready we move in
ready to go is my understanding
um
how does that get done i i believe that
the language for standing up the
facility for june is on her before that
so there would be a seamless transition
as miss ross had been explained to a
previous question that would be our goal
uh making sure that the appropriate
staff were set up
which which does raise one other
question i would want to point out the
committee to be fully clear about the
cost the 15 million is for construction
it does not include the staffing and
other resources that are going to be
needed that will have to be built into
our 2425 budget
so
yeah
you um my question was how you do it you
said that was your hopes of doing that
that is your goal
my question was how do you get that goal
i i you know especially where
especially where current staff members
probably need different qualifications
i'm thinking
so you've gotta
you gotta raise that money you gotta go
to fiscal to get that money to change
from by march of 23. yes and there's
already been work on changing the job
descriptions for the staff at sysc
and changing the operations so that
that's in line to move into a new
facility there are a lot of details to
be worked out but um
until we have more than a dollar in an
actual plan there's only so much that
can be done to make those but the goal
would absolutely be to have staff
trained and in the new positions and
roll into the new facility
and look at the lessons learned from
moving into the new women's prison and
other facilities
and work with the team that's moving and
building the new psychiatric facility so
that we um can get that seamless
transition and have everyone in their
new rule roles at the time that we
transition transition into a new
facility okay thank you
representative yocala
thank you thank you for taking the
question
um
when you talk about um changing people's
roles um i assume that you're talking
about current staff
um changing their role because it
wouldn't be a change unless they were
weren't current um so
what is the benefit of
moving to a different facility
if the staffing is the same uh as far as
the people or are we reducing the number
of people that
that um
we
are going to staff it or increasing
um how does that
is there an actual benefit to moving if
you're keeping the same people
and yes and
represent whereas respectfully the
legislature has already drawn that
directive to us to close down sununu as
part of the hb2 so it's an interesting
question but i think it's moot only
because we're already under uh state law
to close the facility so we do have to
do that and we i believe uh resident
ocala we will continue to be very
thoughtful to make sure that um as it
sets forth in on starting on page two on
line four on roman four that we have
appropriate staff and not only
appropriate staff by standards and
qualifications but also the programs
that we're going to be providing to the
youth that are going to be at that
facility
and to add to that
we are looking at the right
array of staff and in a in a very large
building that we're in now that's going
to look different than in a smaller
space that's configured differently we
can't completely design that until we
know what we're going to be moving into
but the a m report that was provided to
the committee and used over the summer
helps lay out and define what the
appropriate staffing would be
to move more toward the system of care
and providing
a different clinically based approach as
compared to where the sysc facility is
operating now which has substantially
changed in in recent past but is going
to continue to evolve with the movement
into a new facility
representative belanger
thank you madam chair and thank you
again for being here today um as the
only legislator who has been a resident
of the facility
i do have a couple of questions
um
you stated that hhs
miss ross the hhs has got a lot of
projects on their hands right now
how is this going to impact those other
projects and do you see this being
another project on top of the other ones
that you're dealing with do you see that
being a problem
provided we have the staffing and the
resources to
construct a new facility and train folks
to move into it no i think that's that's
how we we scale our work and we're able
to do it um projects and processes
always change that we're used to those
adjustments
and um rights if i could just add to
that we in addition that's why i pointed
out that the 15 million dollars is
really a capital budget uh for standing
up this
facility which is needed and
uh we are thoughtfully working through
or already part of the development of
the state agency efficiency phase of the
budget so this is certainly a priority
for the department and something that
we're going to be thoughtfully working
through in terms of those resources
follow-up less of a follow-up but an
additional question sure regarding
census so i have three questions
regarding census what census today what
was census last week and what was census
last month total
yeah
the last i knew as of
at some point last week it was 12 or 13.
um i can get you those and follow up as
soon as i get back to my phone and and
make an ask of that
but it has been ranging around that 12
for quite a long time
follow-up
i do have a follow-up to that question
and one more following so
representative yokela had alluded to um
hb 254 and what changes would that
affect the census just to clarify in
your
statement you said
based off of hb 254 and the number of 12
youth that are in that facility you do
not expect there to be a drastic change
no not a substantial change that doesn't
mean it won't have an impact on
individuals throughout their cases but
given how far we've reduced the census
over the last decade
and the things that we can't predict as
a result of 254 whether it be that
additional youth are prosecuted into the
adult system who end up spending a
longer time there during the
certification to be prosecuted as an
adult during that process
we don't know what those impacts will be
so we can't we can't predict that there
will be less youth there less days based
on house bill 254
and last question madam chair one more
thank you so
um mr
i'm sorry this is the first time i'm
seeing you what was your name again my
name is john williams and believe it or
not i started in front of this committee
back in 1999.
i apologize very nice to meet you uh
apologies for not getting to that
originally uh mr williams so in your
estimation the 15 million is expected
for construction only is that correct
that is correct as you'll see identified
on page 126 of the commission report
just following up madam chair
one two six yep um so in the bill itself
it states that we will
construct a secured treatment facility
that is no more than 18 beds and we did
talk about the amendment here however as
studies continue to show we expect a
more home-like environment
where is this in this bill where my
expectation is that we are supposed to
be building a more home environment and
less of a prison
excuse me youth detention center big
difference
uh deferring to to miss ross because
this is more of her world of subject
matter but as you see built into the
bill and again working with the
advocates very thoughtfully because the
uh not only the department but the
commit the community that supports
children and healthy environments for
those children identified as part of the
language of the bill in paragraphs
three and four
not only the facility how it was to be
constructed but to get into the details
of the types of programs and how that
would be managed to ensure
the to address the concerns that you're
raising representative
thank you no more further questions
are there any other questions
representative altschiller
thank you madam chair thank you for
being here and um
i'd like to go to page two
um
line nine
section four b
under the facility programming and
operations shall include under b says
use of evidence based practices as
defined in rsa
and
we um i'd like to know why we are not
why we focus in specifically on
evidence-based practices when some of
the newer research coming out is telling
us that evidence-based practices have
limitations in that they are
very unless they unless
unless that evidence-based research
that then results in a practice is done
with
an eye towards
a broad-based application of youth we're
seeing a lot of this evidence-based
research coming through
highly
targeted and
would it not be
in our interest in new hampshire to have
evidence-based and research-based
practices as part of this rsa to allow
for the flexibility
for um
programming
to not be structured in a way that
inhibits the growth
of those that programming
absolutely i completely agree that
using exclusively evidence-based
practices prohibits the expansion of
the availability of evidence-based and
evidence-supported practices consistent
with the system of care we we are
certainly looking to grow that world of
services and make sure
that um evidence-based practices are
used with fidelity so that you're not
using an evidence-based practice with
the wrong population to not get the
outcomes that you want so looking at
evidence supported or researched based
in the inclusion of the service array is
certainly important as we're growing
follow-up so if there were to be an
all a change in that to use
evidence-based and research-based
practices would that be something that
the
that would be supported
the department would not would support
that it's consistent with 135f in the
system of care and it would would help
support the progress at the facility
may follow up follow up
above that facility programming and
operations part a staff qualifications
and standard job descriptions
um an emphasis on treatment with you of
youth with behavioral health challenges
and considerable trauma histories
um it says applicable to the facility so
i could you explain what that would be
because i
i do not understand um
how that could be
is that saying
is this another way of saying
training that emphasize the treatment of
youth with behavioral health challenges
who are in the juvenile justice system
or
yes and we wouldn't without actually
saying that
um well this is focusing on the
operation of the facility but we want
complete integration with the system of
care for children so they're getting
engaged with the care management entity
while they're at the facility in order
to ensure an appropriate discharge plan
and transition into either
community-based services or residential
care as they're moving out when
appropriate so we would expect the same
cat assessment and cans assessments to
be used and to integrate that throughout
their service delivery
i follow that up so in part c
the utilization of the uniform
assessment
i think
if you could
point out for us
where um
where
our stated goals
in doing these reviews
was to provide
for um
was to provide for the children who have
experienced every child who is coming
into these into our facilities
have an asus score of seven or higher
that's just flat out that's it so how
are we addressing their aces scores
while also addressing the juvenile
justice
aspect so where is the treatment of
coming up out of that
simultaneously with the juvenile justice
aspect
because we have leaned a little too
heavy in the juvenile justice
and um and not addressing those a scores
so i think they really are one in the
same in order to provide treatment and
supervision
and ensure a safe and appropriate
transition back to the community you
have to do that every
youth
at sysc is now getting the cans
assessment that the staff down there
have been trained that's the same child
and adolescent needs and strengths tool
that's being used by our community
providers in our residential set
providers and within our acute
psychiatric facilities
so every 90 days that strength and needs
assessment is
should be completed that's part of the
cat assessment which is looking at level
of care for residential um and all being
integrated into their short and long
term goals that are approved by the
court system every 90 days through
family first
are you all sad
for now thank you very much yes
uh representative lebeck
yes thank you um so
on page one uh line 27 it talks about
the space to meet the educational needs
of the youth and
youth with special needs with that space
include like private areas where they
can have tutors or the staff
go over like homework and so that way
they're in
that area and there's no distractions
for them because some kids need that
extra help
absolutely currently sysc has a full
school with multiple classrooms and a
very large space dedicated to that it's
too much for the 12 or so
youth that are down there
but we didn't want to end up in a
home-like setting that didn't have
that ability to fully educate so we
would expect there to be classroom space
tutoring space and the availability to
do assessments and meet with educational
professionals for every youth that's
there
are there any further questions
representative ocala
hi um thank you for taking the question
on on
uh
uh page two line four
it says that um the programming shall
include um but it doesn't say it's
limited to this list so
would you be able to use the
research-based things now without a
change to this legislation
um yes i mean certainly it doesn't say
use exclusively evidence-based but if
the legislature wants to call out that
we
we as a community are going to support
the res the research supported practices
as well
that gives the facility and the staff
better direction as to the intent of the
the legislature in standing up the new
facility
are you all set
representative representative belanger
thank you madam chair just really brief
going back to my sense this question
kind of popped into my head
how many are misdemeanors that are
detained excuse me that are um excuse
whoop okay
in regards to the number of 12 youth
that are currently at sysc right now
how many are misdemeanors how many are
felonies how many are detained and how
many are committed
yeah i mean that changes every day we
would have to go back and get the list i
know we've provided that information
before i think what can be deceiving is
that currently under the system if law
enforcement and the prosecutors know
that they can get the outcome
there is a
high willingness to work with the
parties to reach a settlement that they
that the youth can
uh be committed to syc or held at sysc
and so there there are
plea agreements or settlements um for a
lesser offense even if you look at the
underlying facts that may be higher so
um even if it says misdemeanor today
it could be a felony level behavior or
conduct that may in a future system
in fact be prosecuted as a felony or as
an adult felony charge
follower just if you we could get that
as quickly as you possibly can that
would be greatly appreciated
we will we will ask for that and send it
over
are there any further questions
saying none thank you very much and
thank you reference rice thank you
up next is the honorable neil kirk who
is in support of the bill is introduced
and opposes the bill as amended and he's
asked for three minutes good to see you
sir
good to see you ma'am
good uh good afternoon
members of the committee for the record
i'm neil kirk
i live in where and i'm representing
myself for many years i was a state
representative and served largely on the
finance committee
this committee for at least a decade has
been working toward
treating children in the community and
not in an institutional facility
i finally glommed on to that
in roughly 2016 when i realized that the
population of the sununu center was
declining
significantly and we were spending a lot
of money
on a building designed for 144 when in
fact it was occupied by 60
went down to 40 to 20 and now we're at
12.
and so there was a confluence of
advocates for community treatment for
people and those people
on the budget finance committee were
concerned about paying for this
that met
and we've been working for years
on this project you folks on this
committee have been working to have
children treated in the community house
bill 254 is the latest iteration of that
and folks on finance have been trying to
figure out how we can reduce the cost
one of the problems with having an
institution is that you have fixed costs
whether they're 144 kids or 12 kids
this is an exaggeration
the staff is significantly the same for
example there are 83 staff members today
at sununu
under this bill as the senate proposes
the 18 bed facility there would be
roughly 63
okay a huge number of people for a
relatively small number of children
right now we're spending a million
dollars a year per child
in sununu over a million
so
i
oppose
the amendment that came out of the
senate and support
the bill is introduced by senator
daniels and representative rice
the bill that came out of the senate the
bill that you have before you
um
repeats history
it creates a mini sununu center 18 bed
12 bed a mini sununu center operated by
the state
at at least historically on a reform
school model rather than a treatment
model
that certainly was the result and we
have seen what has happened
hundreds of millions of dollars in
lawsuits as a result of mistreatment of
these juveniles and it's unclear whether
or not at least to me you folks probably
would know better whether the treatment
the children receive forgetting about
the abuse but the treatment they
received
really benefited them at the sununu
center
the
the idea that we would pass the senate
bill suggests that we have learned
nothing from history and we want history
to repeat itself
do we expect another couple hundred
million dollars of lawsuits five ten
twenty years from now
it's a bad approach it's not
child-centered it's not
treatment-centered the bill is
introduced
the daniel's rice bill took a different
approach
it said basically we're going to provide
treatment in the community
in a
non-profit
private sector run facility which might
by the way
if it's done correctly make the children
eligible for medicaid cost sharing which
is not the case now at the sununu center
um
one of the advantages of doing this is
the cost to the state are variable
instead of the fixed cost and by the way
this bill doesn't talk anything about
the operating expenses roughly eight to
nine uh nine to ten million dollars a
year in addition to the 15 million
dollar construction cost
if
these children are in a community
facility
then we pay per child per day
a saving of roughly one-third if there
are three or four children the cost to
the state will be four million a year if
there are six
to eight children the cost will be eight
million a year if we go with the bill as
as it came over from the senate we're
hit with a fixed cost of nine to ten
million dollars a year regardless of the
number of children and if 254 passes i
believe there will be a significant drop
in the number of children who are
need treatment in sununu or the
replacement facility
so the bill is introduced puts treatment
at the center
in a private nonprofit
provider secure facility
that just might be eligible as i say for
medicaid cost sharing
i urge the committee to reject what the
senate has proposed and come up with
what the senate chairman and your
committee chairman originally proposed
which was child center treatment center
and cost-effective
there's no reason to do anything else
and by the way i understand you have a
deadline
if you don't have an opportunity today
to make the tweaks that are necessary to
the original bill my understanding this
bill is going to house finance
and i know some of the folks on division
three there are very sensitive to this
issue and will be more than
accommodating to the committee if the
chairman would approach them and say
we didn't have time to do a b and c
please tweak the bill on these policy
issues
thank you madam chairman i'd be pleased
to answer any questions thank you
representative belanger
thank you madam chair and thank you
honorable neil kirk for being here today
i've heard a lot of great things about
you and i apologize for not serving with
you
um
so
you alluded to medicaid cost sharing is
that correct yes where do you get that
there are provisions in federal law that
make a child who is medicaid eligible
ineligible to have his
cost of
treatment
paid for or co-share paid for by
medicaid if he is in a public
institution
and the sununu center qualifies as a
public institution
there is an exception
if the facility has less than 15 beds
and
takes in or makes available those beds
to other
children who are not necessarily in the
same category and depending on upon how
the department would contract this we
might find ourselves in a private sector
non-profit facility that has 12 to 16
beds some of which would be available to
non-sununu
excuse me non-committed
type children and therefore it would
qualify for or could qualify for
medicaid
follow-up
so if we could qualify for medicaid why
aren't we qualifying for medicaid now we
can't qualify for medicaid now sir
because we have a facility that is a
public institution as defined by the
feds and that immediately disqualifies
the child from receiving medicaid
sharing for his incarceration costs
moreover that facility has a capacity of
144 and the maximum under federal law
i believe is 16.
final follow-up thank you for answering
the question so
of course i didn't pull up the previous
bill that was
introduced in the senate but i do
believe that it's still required for
secure treatment facility
which
my understanding of medicaid
reimbursement is that it would not be
eligible
for reimbursement provided that it is a
secure treatment facility so that's
where i question that we
can do that i've heard both
sides of the argument say yes and i and
i've heard from sides that say no
so
finding
you know finding this information
to its full extent and finding that
statute and federal understanding would
be beneficial
in my decision making process because my
understanding i don't have it in front
of me
it says no we can't if it's privatized
because it is a secured facility
it's not the security of the facility
it's the fact that it's a public
institution
there are people who will follow me and
testifying who can add to this
and i have a piece i hope i brought it
with me that i will share with you i
don't have enough copies for everyone
and i understand you have a timing issue
that you could read and it might perhaps
assuage your concerns
but i point out to you regardless of
whether or not medicaid would cost share
the original bill is introduced is a
better bill
because it will save us money even if we
pay for it as we do with the sununu
center with 100 general funds
so i don't want that to be i don't want
the medicaid cost sharing to be a red
herring it's a possible bonus
but it's not the reason for going back
to the original bill
another
representative long
thank you madam chair and uh
representative i apologize for serving
with you
apology accepted okay thank you
uh the um
you mentioned for 12 years at least
we've been going for a community based
correct
so how many facilities would there be
even if they're private facilities so
community base means
a manchester resident
would be in the manchester area because
that's their community
aware
remember where youth would be in
a facility somewheres
in within that community is that my
understanding
no
there would be a single facility
provided by the private nonprofit
located
somewhere in the state and both
manchester and where children
committed to that facility would go
there
there are other facilities which provide
residential services today under the
service of of
care program throughout the state
but that's very different from what
we're talking about here
this is a single facility for this very
small group of children who need
a secure facility to both protect
themselves from themselves and or to
protect the community from themselves
that's the purpose of this bill
to replace the sununu center with
something other than that right follow
up for me so community base is
not the case
community based is not the case for this
very small three to eight to ten twelve
children you're correct okay very good
thank you
are there any further questions
am i seeing none thank you very much
thank you madam chairman thank you
members of the committee
up next is cassandra chan
sanchez
to speak in support of the bills she
does have written testimony
yes
hi
welcome to the children and family law
committee it's so nice to see you again
thank you for having me it's a pleasure
to be here
i'm hoping that we can continue to work
together in the future i look forward to
oh yes
absolutely um and so today i have with
me the associate child advocate emily
lawrence to help answer questions as
this is only my third day in the role
she's much more of an expert on this
bill as i am at this point but i've done
my best to catch up as quickly as i can
so today we are here in support of
senate bill 458 as it has been amended
in the spring of 2021 new hampshire took
firm footing and transitioning of the
juvenile justice system
with enhanced resources new pathways to
by diverting children from the system
and in house bill 2 closure of the
sprawling youth prison and detention
center
these accomplishments brought new
hampshire into alignment with the latest
science on child development in
particular brain development
we understand there is concern about the
size of the structure and number of beds
proposed at the new facility we do agree
and we advocate we did advocate for the
language of no more than 18 beds we
would support amending the current
language for fewer bets
several initiatives that were
considerably delayed but are now
underway predict even less need for
the secure detention center and
confinement facility in the near future
under changes being phased in from 2021
senate bill 94
pre-petition assessments are provided
proving to be successful in diverting
children from the system estimated
reports of the first two months include
80 assessments completed preliminary
data shows 70 percent have resulted in
children being diverted from court 20
percent have instead accessed
behavioral health services such as
multi-step systemic therapy
50 are accessing local community
supports and
traditional diversion programs
furthermore very recently the court
rules of probation or conditions of
release were changed from 20
overwhelming limitations to just four
and an individualized plan
not attending school or not following
curfew are concerns of course but we do
not consider those criminal acts
individualized plans for each child will
address these behaviors and minimize the
need for them to be in a secure setting
the office supports the adjusted time to
time as articulated on page 1 line 13
through 16 of the amended version that
provides the department until june 30th
2024 to complete the project
the community and legislature have
demonstrated a lack of trust in the
department's plan which to some degree
is understandable given the ongoing
criminal investigations
we feel that we must have confidence in
the many community based rollouts that
are currently taking place including the
2021 senate bill 94 allowing the
assessments
of need prior to the delinquency
petitions being filed
our impression is that a state-owned
facility will provide the best return on
investment and most flexible use
of the investment
as stated page 2 line 25-28
by remaining state-run the oca has the
ability to maintain oversight with
access and ease
to gain records and immediately respond
when there are incidents within the
center
thank you for taking my testimony and
allowing me to explain
why we support the amended version of
senate bill 458
i'm open for any questions okay thank
you representative yokela
thank you thank you for taking the
question um
if
as the previous speaker suggested we not
um have a state-run facility um
would you
and and contracted that out um
would
your would you have concerns about that
um
because it seemed like your testimony
said that there implied that your your
support was contingent on it being a
state-run facility
well we are in support of it being a
state-run facility um specifically
because of the ease of the office of the
child advocate gaining immediate access
to records and having oversight um
within our
access to the the records via the
computer system um the the case work
management system so that just makes it
it provides us more ease in getting
access we do still have oversight in
any agency that is serving children
across the state so we would still have
the oversight it is the ease for us to
gain access and to immediately respond
when something happens as
we have seen with the sununu center um i
think one thing that's important to note
as well is that
we have only been running for four years
so our oversight of the sununu center is
very new and so although there have been
many complaints over time our
involvement has not been with all of
those complaints
are there any further questions
representative long
thank you madam chair and
congratulations uh mr sanchez thank you
uh
so so on uh page two starting on line 32
um august 1st 2022 they begin reporting
to the legislative joint committee
on health and human services and to your
office
until a facility is operational
should those reports continue to your
office while the facility is operational
we do feel that those should absolutely
continue to come to our office yes okay
great thank you
representative schiller did you yep okay
thank you madam chair welcome thank you
congratulations thank you
um
within the testimony from the office of
the child advocate you um on the second
page
you outlined that um
the office of the child advocate urges
investment in a small use flexibility
for when no children are present with
flexible staff job descriptions that can
shift to other activities with
consistent employment could you
elaborate on what that looks like
what did you have in mind yes emily can
you help me answer that so i think part
part of that thinking was that you'd
have staff that could shift into the
community to help kids as they're
in the community so if we're gonna have
and this is somewhat in alignment with
the changes that came through with
senate bill 94 which is working to
divert kids one from even coming into
the system but then if they do come into
the system for them to each have
individualized plans and so if you have
staff that could be working with those
kids while they're in the community to
support them maybe support their
juvenile probation and parole officers
um those could be flexible use staff
that was the intent
nice
follow-up
so so
the intent from the office of the child
advocate is to provide more supports
across the board for those children as
they move through the system and not
rely completely
on juvenile justice but provide those
supports as they
um
as they
transition out of
of their
high need
time at the center
to
gradual
um reintegration into their communities
so it's not a full drop off is that what
you're saying definitely thank you and
in fact right now they're start they're
trying to do that um and integrate that
uh plan into the kids that they're
working with that's a new to the extent
that they can
have staff
supporting them in the community
may fall with one more one more thank
you um and so to that end
uh would the office of the child
advocates support on page two
of the amended bill
i don't know where it would be in the
original but nonetheless
um
line nine part b
use of evidence-based practices and
research-based practices
yes yes we would
um we were looking at the language where
it says the facility and programming
which is line four the facility and
programming and operations shall include
um so not keeping it restricted to
evidence evidence-based but also being
able to include other research based
that will be potentially fit a better
fit for that specific child
last question madam chair sure um on
that same
on that same line
would the office of the child advocate
support adding the phrase
trauma-informed evidence-based practices
and research-based practices
yes absolutely thank you
representative belanger
thank you madam chair and thank you so
much for being here today so much
congratulations on your appointment
looking forward to working with you
moving forward
um
have you had a chance to look at the
bill that was introduced i know it's
your third day yes
okay yes i have yeah thank you
um
can you
what would be the difference of
completely privatizing this and what
hurdles do you think it would be
for the office of the child advocate if
this is i'm not saying this is what's
going to happen i just want to clarify
if in the instance it was a completely
privatized situation
i think one in which we were speaking
about was the the ease of access we do
understand that we have that in our
newer jurisdiction but um at this point
that's not very well known in the
community we're working to we're working
on that initiative to
inform the entire community that we have
expanded our jurisdiction so it is the
access to the clinical notes and the
incidents immediately as they occur
as one primary concern the other that we
spoke about was the ability to have the
flexible staffing
if they are you know state workers
there's some flexibility and
and the ability to
use them elsewhere if the facility is
not housing the numbers which we feel at
some point with all these other
initiatives that the numbers are going
to greatly reduce from a a full
um
what's represented here 18 better or
potential the the lesser number of 12
bed to be even lesser than that so then
being able to use that staff in a
different capacity
thank you
are there any further questions
seeing them thank you very much thank
you and up next is michelle wangren with
new hampshire legal assistance to speak
in support of the bill for five minutes
how are you i'm doing well good
afternoon oh i'm sorry one second um
emily will you just fill out a pink card
since you spoke to thank you
would it be okay if i present with karen
rosenberg from disability's right center
sure
knock two birds there you go
thank you thank you
do you want to start
good afternoon i'm karen rosenberg i'm
the policy director of the disability
rights center and i'm here with michelle
michelle wongren i am the youth law
project director at new hampshire legal
assistance and we are testifying in
support of sb 458 and we're representing
not just our agencies but also the
juvenile rights policy group which is a
group of non-profit
organizations that advocate for
vulnerable youth that includes waypoint
new hampshire legal assistance the aclu
of new hampshire
new futures and my organization the
disability rights center um and
as this this is difficult we're dealing
with the most vulnerable children who
are really challenging and we're dealing
with kids who have
high intensive treatment needs um and
also who are really isolated from their
communities
um as a state when we're considering
closing the sununu center
our goal should make sure be to make
sure that the youth who are committed to
a locked facility because it's necessary
for them at some juncture in their lives
for themselves to receive treatment or
because they're unsafe and for the
safety of our community we need to make
sure that they're going to be better off
leaving than they were when they came in
and that they're prepared to be living
with their families attending their
schools graduating from high school
maybe going to secondary school
post-secondary school and joining the
workforce not ending up at our facility
that's way worse on north state street
concord
we don't support every aspect of this
bill
we're happy to learn of the propose of a
proposal for you to consider an
amendment to look at a smaller
number because really it would be
we think that most children can have
their needs met in the community so
getting down to nine or 12 beds with
some flexibility makes a lot of sense to
us and as i heard some of your
frustration
the amount of time that um
potentially could be available to get
this done seems lengthy to me i am not
in construction never had been but it
seems like a very long time
so if there was you know some amendment
to shorten that time or shorten that
escape hatch that's fine with us
but
this bill requires a child-centered
treatment approach and it requires that
it be done in a facility where we know
there is significant oversight and
michelle will talk about why we can
think that this can be accomplished much
more easily and much more effectively at
a publicly owned and operated facility
it does provide i think there were some
questions about transition
and what the bill does require is that
this that dcyf immediately began
implementing evidence-based practices at
the sununu center with qualified staff
and that the provisions in sb 458
that are in um i think it's section
three but it's roman numeral four on
page
two if i'm looking at the correct
version of the bill i think i am that
all that all of these provisions with
staff competency and the practices that
are used which actually doesn't do
include the way we define evidence-based
practices includes research based so
it's not just limited um but that's how
we just happened to define it in law
so it requires that all of these
safeguards and the real-time access that
the oca has to not just being able to go
into the facility but also access to
their case management database
in place continue
at sununu center and then at the
replacement facility so and then they're
also
the bill does not call for any kind of
gap
in services for these the children who
need such a secure setting so what this
spill does and you can see this on
it's page
three
and it's um
section i think it's roman numeral seven
and
and then it continues on to section two
that basically
the the the facility that is now the
sununu center continues to operate
in in alliance with you know with these
practices and trained staff
until the opening day of the new
facility so we aren't leaving kids in
limbo in this bill so i think that was a
concern that you all raised so that
is is not something um we think this is
um the way to do this in a fiscally
sound way that actually takes care of
kids we don't believe that medicaid will
ever cover
children being locked in a facility
there are there is a provision in
medicaid that allows for the coverage of
psychiatric resident residential
treatment but not in unlocked facilities
so um michelle maybe you should take it
from here thank you yeah before
launching into another issue i will just
point out i was doing some research as
that conversation was happening and i
found um some interpretation of the
center for medicaid services
guidance
that says that cms regulations define a
public institution i'm sorry hold on
i was a i won't read you the whole thing
cms guidance has interpreted
correctional facilities broadly to
include private facilities that are
under direct contract with a
governmental entity to provide
correctional services or that are
otherwise acting as an institution for
incarceration
so i would be happy to do some more
research to figure out um whether there
are any loopholes in that but my
understanding has always been that
medicaid will not cover children who are
in a locked-in facility um that and you
know perhaps if there were a locked
facility that was
not through a contract with the state
i don't know how that would possibly
occur but if there is a contract with
the state for a locked facility they are
considered a public institution under
the center for medicaid services
guidance
so um so if i can continue talking i saw
a hand raised if it's on that issue i'm
happy to take questions on that now
okay brief
all i was going to ask and thank you
madam chair is that you um forward that
um to me but i appreciate it i'm sure
other members would appreciate that
being fortunate you would send it to the
committee i would appreciate it so i'll
be honest that this this i was doing a
quick google search and it was it was
guidance from a law firm that is well
known for working with state agencies
and so is interpretation of of
their interpretation of the guidance but
i i can find the guidance if it's there
i will find it
or if i can't for whatever reason i will
send you the guidance that i just i just
cited to you
um
so one of the other things that that the
committee has heard today is that
perhaps dcyf isn't isn't equipped to
manage a new facility and maybe
shouldn't have the opportunity to do
that and one of the reasons is because
we all know that there are some major
lawsuits going on about conditions at
the current facility in the former
facility
which is going to cost the state upwards
of 100 million dollars
um
i understand that concern i do i have
spent my career working with children in
the juvenile justice system those
children have been in private facilities
they've been in public facilities
they've been at the sununu center
and and i can tell you that none of
those facilities is everything we would
like it to be and more they certainly
are nothing the children would like them
to be and more
but what i can say is that in my over a
decade doing this we have gotten so much
better and the state has gotten so much
better when the circumstances that
existed in these lawsuits occurred
we were in a different we were in a
different space we didn't have the
system of care we didn't have a
therapeutic model which we are working
towards and which this bill mandates
that we move towards by march 2023 even
before the new facility is complete and
we didn't have the real time oversight
by the office of the child advocate
with those pieces
in place
we are a we have a very transparent
system that not only is transparent to
an oversight agency but is also
transparent in the sense that we
that they are covered by the right to
know law we can ask for lawsuits against
the agency at any time and settlement
agreements that the agency has entered
into at any time we do not have that
ability when it comes to a private
facility a private facility is not
subject to the right to know law it it
can enter into confidential settlement
agreements that we will never see that
we'll never see the light of day and we
don't know what's happening at those
facilities we do know that they're not
perfect they are subject to
licensing requirements and the licensing
violations are are public and if you
were to go into any new hampshire
private facility and look at their via
licensing violations you will see a very
robust list of them that directly impact
the safety of youth but again
those
there's there's a lot more scrutiny on
the agency itself because of the
transparency that we have and because of
the oversight that it's under that can't
be lost in this and so while we're
looking at
hundreds of millions of dollars of
lawsuits because we had a poorly managed
system at some point in the past it
doesn't mean that we're we're still
there and and i just don't want the
committee to lose sight of everything
that we have gained through the office
of the child advocate and that real-time
oversight where they have an integrated
case management system where they can
look at the records of any child at any
moment
that system does not exist with the
private facilities they don't have the
same case management system they don't
some of them don't even keep their lab
their records electronically so while
the office of the child advocate could
go at any time and meet with any child
and have access that way in fact i spoke
with moira a few weeks ago and she said
that if she really wanted to she could
stay the night that's great and i
encourage anyone to do that to see
what's going on but she doesn't
but the office of the child advocate
does not have access to those records um
and i and i think that that's a
a level of oversight that we don't want
to go backwards from
um
so then um i think so a lot of things
have been covered i have a whole list of
other things that i wanted to talk about
and i don't want to waste your time
though so let me just
um
i think we have covered
everything else that i
wanted to tell you so i'd be happy to um
to take any questions and and be either
myself or attorney rosenberg may have
answers are there any questions
representative all chiller
thank you madam chair thank you very
much for being here to answer these
questions and
i wonder if you'll um
if this if this might be in your scope
we heard some testimony
from in relation to another bill
but applies the instance applies here
should these services be privatized
or even partially privatized
would there be or is it your opinion
that there might be
a problem with getting
liability insurance
for these private facilities we are
hearing
that in other high conflict
child
services
they are losing their limited liability
umbrella policies is that something that
would be a co that would be a problem if
we were to do the same with this type of
facility
i mean i know that there's someone else
here who um
keith kennedy from waypoint could
address that for you if you were to call
on him i know he doesn't didn't sign up
to testify but it's my understanding
that that is an issue
for um some of the private companies but
i i don't feel that i'm qualified to
answer that really yeah and and one of
the things i i will say just
tangentially related to the the issue of
liability is
what hasn't been thought out in terms of
privatization
is what's going to happen
if the private
facility that were to take this contract
does not live up to its obligations so
we're asking the state to spend
potentially a million or more dollars
hardening a facility and then expecting
that it would be subject to a contract
with the state
where it has to meet certain
deliverables and it has to meet certain
safety requirements and when you think
about how the contracts work the state
has oversight of that
and if the if if the facility is not
meeting its deliverables and not meeting
its safety standards the recourse is to
pull the contract but if we've invested
all of these this money into a single
facility and expect that facility to
then serve children under certain
expectations
we don't have that recourse to pull the
contract because then where would the
children go
if it's a state facility
then
the state is responsible for managing it
if if it can't staff its facility just
as it did with covid it can pull in
staffing from other places so when the
sununu center was not able to staff
itself properly it was able to call upon
the juvenile probation officers to
assist with staffing it made sure that
it was able to meet the standards that
it needed to to ensure the safety of
youth that's not something that could
happen in private facilities and i and
and i just don't know what the recourse
would be other than yanking the contract
and and wasting the state dollars
putting all our eggs in this basket well
or
i'm sorry or
not doing anything
and letting the children suffer in poor
conditions
yeah i mean a couple things one is that
i'm
one thing to keep in mind is the state
does have a contract with dartmouth
medical center and so they've been able
to secure really high qualified
psychiatric services and psychologists
so even though there's a workforce
shortage in healthcare
we know that they have the ability to
secure the qualified staff treatment
staff that's really needed for these
kids and as far as pulling a contract
i was the lead investigator in the
lakeview investigation several years ago
which many of you may have remember
included a school for kids a residential
school
and a facility for adults that was
licensed by our state and also was an
approved special education placement for
children and what our office uncovered
was significant abuse physical abuse
emotional abuse all kinds and
we
our governor made the you know initially
just said no more placements there and
eventually the license was revoked and
i mean i was
proud of the work that i led to uncover
this but i'll tell you it was very
difficult because when that facility
closed there were not places to absorb
those children and adults who had been
yet subjected to abuse and now they had
nowhere to go and we scurried around and
tried to help people but some people
from new hampshire ended up in florida i
mean those are adults
children ended up in different
placements so it is a problem
are there any further questions
all right sing none thank you very much
thank you for your time
okay last pink card
the members are getting hungry
john dejoy
thank you ma'am sharon i i hate standing
between any of you and and lunch
so
please bear with me i
i may repeat i will do my best not to
repeat
but
issue i don't i want to make sure i
don't leave anything out that is
relevant there are a number of comments
that were made throughout the hearing
today that
i would like to respond to some i will
not i will not wade into
um
madam chair members of the committee
it's pleasure to be before the children
family law committee today for the
record my name is john dejoy i rise in
opposition to the senate past
senate bill 458
i
continue to support the
senate bill 458 as was originally
introduced which you've heard repeatedly
today and what we have is we have two
very different approaches so i support
the originally introduced approach and
i'll explain why
before i begin i do want to just a
moment of personal privilege and
acknowledge a very dear friend of mine
catherine rogers
i don't bring her up today because of
what happened
but i bring her up today to point out
that
kathy and i kathy has worked with me on
this issue
for as long as i have worked on this
issue
i've worked with adolescents in some
capacity or another for more than 35
years
mostly in the psychiatric mental health
realm
i've been aware of and working on this
issue to close this center
since it opened
in 2006 seven
but when
we talk about closing sununu
we talk about moving children to a
treatment facility that provides
humane trauma-informed care
that gives the children the best chance
of success
we don't talk about closing sununu to
build a mini sununu
that's not closing at that we might as
well stay where they are
we put great emphasis on the state law
which says that children ought to be in
them in the least restrictive
alternative
appropriate alternative
we think that is what should drive
everything that we work on regarding
children
new hampshire and our juvenile justice
system finds itself at a crossroad
we found ourselves at a similar
crossroad
20 years ago
following the 1990s the rise in crime
an apparent rise in juvenile crime
this legislature chose to build 144 bid
facility at that point and that decision
framed the entirety of our juveniles
justice system for the next 20 years up
until where we are now
we're at a similar crossroads today
we are discussing whether we should
build the mini sununu
as recommended in this bill before you
recommended by dcyf
or whether we should
fully include these six to 12 children
in the existing children's behavioral
health system of care
now
i don't
consider youth prison
as part of the system of care
i do consider psychiatric
hospitalization
psychiatric residential treatment
facilities part of the system of care
but most kids don't move through prison
that's why it's not part of the system
of care
a colleague of mine used to testify
before this committee and others
frequently
and he said the same thing
every time
new hampshire has a long history
of over-incarcerating
low-level offenders
that's why this committee passed 254
last year
because you understood that we
over-incarcerate low-level offenders i
would add to that new hampshire has
and is overly reliant
on institutional levels of care
both among children and adults
what the original 458 is introduced
gives us the opportunity to do
is to move away from that
in an organized safe manner
to a system that can give kids the best
chance to succeed
there are lots of reasons i'm going to
share a couple there are lots of reasons
why a mini sununu does not make sense
chief among them is that the
census in fiscal year 21 averaged about
12.
the census this fiscal year is under 12
i think it's about 11 and three quarters
so we're seeing that you know there's
some stagnation in the census but we
also see the number of detained kids
tends to be going up month over month
while the number of committed kids tends
to be going down
and that ms ross appropriately said
that's variable it is variable but we're
having more and more detained kids than
we've ever had before through the
history of this facility
and you can see that through the data
over the last
over the last decade
it's also important to understand that
dcyf has testified repeatedly that 75
percent of the kids
at sununu at sysc
are dealing with behavioral health
issues
so we're looking for the best way to
treat these kids
makes sense but we also know that kids
that are committed or detained at sununu
and are released
nearly two-thirds of the time
return to sununu
if 66
of people fail at anything
that's not giving kids the best chance
to recover
we have a better way and it's the it's
the way that i'm talking about in the
original senate bill 458.
just for for illustration
assuming there's 12 kids there which is
what it's been lately
eight of the kids who were discharged
will return to sununu
8 out of 12.
bear with me i moved some passages
around
um
the most straightforward solution is the
original senate bill 458 and add to the
original language more robust oversight
as you've heard today is required it was
it was not included in the original
language through numerous conversations
it makes sense to make to add more
robust oversight and i'll i'll speak to
that
dcyf already has oversight
as the contractor the oca as you heard
already has oversight
you heard ms wagner and talk about
non-disclosure agreements and and
private agreements
one of the oversight measures we think
would be essential is that contractually
the department ought to specify with the
provider
that there can be no nda's to shield
them from from any untoward events or
any critical incident events that only
seems reasonable i'm would even suggest
giving the oca an additional staff
person
for the next two years
with their only job being to oversee
this new contracted facility of six to
twelve kids
and at the end of a year or two
you all can talk to the oca about
whether that's necessary
and then use the oca can use that staff
person for whatever she sees fit
you see
we should never be afraid of oversight
and transparency so the more
transparency oversight we want to add to
the original 458
bring it on i'm all in for as much
oversight as we can
we all want the same thing we all want
kids
to be protected
there's a perception
and you you heard inklings of it but
there's a perception that these are
dangerous kids
and occasionally
rarely
in new hampshire there are children who
commit heinous crimes we can name them
that's how infrequently it happens
the vast majority of kids we're talking
about are not dangerous kids what they
are is their kids who have had a really
rough start either for personal or
family circumstances
they have the most high
the most complex needs of any children
in our state
and the way we up until now have
responded to them is by putting them in
jail
we as a state can and should do better
with these children
they need complex needs yes they do
stupid stuff and come into contact with
law enforcement
they ought to be held
accountable but their life shouldn't be
destroyed because of it
right as i as i testified to senate
judiciary the other day
house bill 254 the only consequence
that's off the table is going to sununu
every other consequence continues to be
on the table but to the extent that we
can keep these kids in in or close to
their home community that's what we
ought to be doing that's the purpose of
the system of care
the system of care is not just group
homes it's a full range of care to
provide the right care at the right
moment in the kids life in the right
location
now by the time the kid gets into court
it may be a little late
to go
upstream but as we do this
as we focus on these kids as being
worthy of this level of care
we will intervene in the future
consequences to prevent them from need
from from offending again
you've heard
allegations that
private facilities and let me just say i
i reject the concept that the original
bill privatizes the juvenile justice
system it does not
what it does is it treats juvenile
justice or kids in the juvenile justice
system the same way every other child in
the system of care is treated
every program in the system of care is
contracted
this is nothing more than a contract is
what it is
but let me just stipulate any
abuse towards any child in any location
is unacceptable
none of us would tolerate that
and to accept for the moment
that the arguments
um
hold up to accept for a moment that dcyf
and the child advocate have full
oversight authority which we've heard
that they do
regarding the group homes
i'm not aware of any contracts that have
been removed from group homes
in the last several years i know that
one was referenced that i'm not familiar
with in the last several years regarding
in regard to abusive behavior
the oca did an investigation in december
of a provider and came back with
findings
the department
in their public statement through the
media talked about how they have a
contracted system provide sufficient
oversight
so the department believes they are
providing sufficient oversight at the at
the current time
um
let's contrast though that type of
system of care
community-based system that i've been
talking about with the sununu youth
services center there are currently 11
staff members
who are incarcerated for various
offenses primarily sexual assault or
some version of sexual assault more than
500 children
have alleged
abuse at that facility
i recently spoke with plaintiff
attorneys
plaintiff attorneys have told me
currently the most recent allegation of
abuse that they have
is 2018
doesn't mean there's nothing newer
doesn't mean there will be anything
newer but what they have told me is that
currently the most
current allegation is from 2018.
we also have you heard about the victims
compensation but i don't even want to
talk about the compensation fund and
i'll tell you why
we're talking about
we're not talking about money we get
lost in the money we get lost in the
oversight we get lost in we lose the
kids in this
we're talking about children
we need to focus on this as though their
lives depended on it
because it does
i will the final point that i'll make to
you
is that
if to the extent that group homes treat
children badly please do not forget
that we have more than 300 children in
residential care
on any given month and slightly under
that now based on the health and human
services dashboard if these six to 12
children in juvenile justice if the
group homes are not appropriate for them
why do we have 300 other children
in some of the same facilities
why aren't we actively investigating
every group home removing every child
the answer is simple
that can there are concerns
but the concerns that addressed don't
represent systemic
concerns they represent
um
anecdotal concerns nonetheless important
but not systemic
to end my testimony representative
rogers
a couple of weeks ago
she received a letter during her work
with the uh
the compensation fund
she told me this letter is the most
compelling letter from a victim of
sununu abuse that she has received and
has asked me to read it into the record
i'm not going to read any of the record
i can madam chair
i'm not going to read into the record
because of time but i do i'm going to
give you a copy but i want to excerpt a
couple of points that i think are really
important
this is written by a 30 31 year old man
currently incarcerated at the northern
correctional facility in berlin
and he starts by saying i'm a survivor
and vic and victim of whitey's of the
ydc state-run facility and abuse scandal
but he goes on to say he was abused at
other facilities as well not just at ydc
he talks at length of what he refers to
as years of abuse torture says sexually
physically mentally emotionally
nothing can ever take that away
but he
asks for the state to acknowledge
responsibility for what has happened to
children he believes that is essential
both for the state and for the victims
to be able to put some put some closure
he goes on to say that these
his physical wounds have healed
but the scars
the torture the trauma
have not and will never go away for this
man
he talks about his his symptoms
depression flashback shame fear terror
and he says i feel it is
important it is very important for the
representatives of new hampshire to
understand that this abuse is not
temporary
the effects
are forever
with that i would
humbly ask
folks to
please consider the original bill
i believe
that even if it needs more work
it is a far more child-centered bill
takes into consideration
most of the concerns that have been
talked about today and the ones that
haven't i'm always willing to work with
anybody to make it a better bill
are there any questions
thank you so much
sure
it will be quick it's relative to house
bill 254
i know that there's uh
miss ross and she wouldn't be surprised
if she was still here
that i disagree with her
what i received in terms of data
via house finance were 2019 and 2020
all the children who were either
detained or committed to the sununu
center and all of the charges it didn't
have the confining charge
i don't know what the confining charge
was it had all of the charges that those
children were
subject to
i can tell you that more than fifty
percent of the children in those two
years were in sununu for misdemeanor
offenses
i can tell you that if 254 passed
about eight or nine percent of all of
the charges
only eight or nine percent of all the
charges
would have been met for confinement at
sununu
does it mean they'll only be eight or
nine percent of the kids because there's
multiple charges but
92 percent of the charges did not meet
the conditions of house bill 254 and
i'll leave it at that
thank you
okay so yep okay i got i got one more
too i lied before so we'll take yours
too
um but i just want to let the committee
members know that what we'll do is when
we're done with this we'll hear the next
bill quickly if it's because it's almost
1 30 and then we'll break for lunch
and and i apologize i really did not
plan well today so i'm so sorry so up
next is representative mary jane walner
she's asked for two minutes
where'd he go thank you madam chair and
i'm not going to take two minutes i'm
going to take much less than that
because i think
you've had a full morning of um
hearing testimony
but i will say that i was so
disappointed
when i saw what came back from the
senate
i've been working on this issue for many
years mostly through the finance
committee
and looking at the sununu center in the
the cost of running the sununu center
but again what came back from the senate
was again a focus on the building
and not on moving
towards caring for these young people
with community-based services
a number of the children
will need secure
residential placement
but we know that many of these children
would be better served in their
community
and in their own homes
some of these children
and families need services the whole
family needs services
not just the child
and
moving them into residential
incarceration does not meet the needs of
the full of the whole family and
possibly other children in the family
this bill mo is
to me this bill feels like we're taking
another step backwards
it's again it's incarceration of these
children and not looking
to what we could be doing for them in
their own communities
with community-based services
i do not see this bill as it is written
um to move us any closer to providing
for care for children in the least
restrictive environment
i know your committee has a huge
undertaking
that needs to happen i guess before five
o'clock tonight
you have so much information to work
with i hope that some of you have been
able to look at the original bill
and um
see some of the
parts of that bill that
are definitely would definitely move us
towards caring for children in a much
more less restrictive environment
and um
for that
and then i think it will move on to the
finance committee where i think there
are a number of financial questions
about this bill it the way it came back
from the senate it seems like it's
um
there are just so many questions to be
answered around the finances of it
thank you i'm glad to answer any
questions if i can are there any
questions
great seeing them thank you so much
and last but not least i am not
accepting any more pink cards on this
bill
is keith keane to speak for two minutes
in support of the bill
madam chairman represent committee my
name is keith kinning i'm the uh
advocate director at waypoint i know you
want to eat and i want to get to my car
before i get a ticket so i'm going to
make this really really fast um a couple
things i want to make it clear that
juvenile reform project doesn't support
putting one child in a locked facility
that doesn't belong there but
there are some children that are
dangerous to themselves or to the
community that need to be in a locked
facility and i will tell you whether you
have this state build it or if a
non-profit builds it because of priya
which you guys understand because of
certain children that are certified as
an adult you are going to have to have a
locked facility in this state so you
you're not going to get around that
i think it's unfair
to continue to call it a mini sununu any
more than it's unfair to call it a mini
granite pathways um let's not forget the
state invested two million dollars in
granite pathways
ended up closing it under a year
because children were sexually abused
and three of them almost died at that
facility
so
i just think you need to keep that in
mind as you're going forward and finally
you know we're non-profits but we're not
stupid um you know there's this idea
that somehow out there we're just gonna
have to pay any private facility
just for the people they're taking care
of it doesn't work that way if you ask a
facility to make room for
nine kids they're gonna have to staff
for nine kids and whether one child is
there or two children are there you
still have to pay that amount of money
and so i think there's a bit of a
misnomer going on here that somehow
going to a private or you know facility
is going to save so much more money um i
just don't think that's true so i just
wanted to make those four quick points
and i'm happy to take any questions are
there any questions
all right so again thank you so much i
will close the public hearing on
um house
senate bill 458 we'll take a seven
minute break be back for 1 30 and then i
promise we'll go to lunch and i
apologize
that we're running so far behind
okay
oh i've seen it
all right
you wanna
exactly and they wanted to connect them
so i told them
okay
i'm here
so she
yes
oh
all right i'm going to open the public
hearing on senate bill 446 and i will
call on senator becky whitley who's
asked for 10 minutes i don't even need
to and she doesn't even need 10 minutes
i'm going to hold to it
thank you madam chair good afternoon
members of the committee for the record
my name is becky whitley and i'm honored
to serve senate district 15 including
the communities of concord henniker
hopkinton and warner
so the bill before you senate bill 446
as it was introduced established a child
care workforce fund to provide grants to
eligible child care programs
for
workforce recruitment and retention
bonus bonuses and benefits uh the bill
originally made an appropriation to the
fund for the purposes of establishing
and administrating the grant but what
you have before you is compromised
language that we passed over in the
senate
the bill maintains the important
findings and purpose of the underlying
bill but replaces the remainder of the
bill with the directive to the
department of health and human services
so pursuant to the version you have
before you the department is charged
with developing a plan in consultation
with the advisory council on child care
that plan is due june 30th
and the plan is to foster sustainable
child care work opportunities for
working families and businesses and
we're a little prescriptive in what the
plan needs to do because of the robust
testimony we heard in the senate about
the importance to address the child care
workforce which is the workforce behind
the workforce so the plan must focus on
strategies to rapidly increase
uh recruitment and retention of staffing
at child care facilities it must include
consideration of recruitment and
retention bonus bonus and benefit
programs for certain child care employee
employers strategies to ensure a future
workforce costs for facilities and
strategies to increase access and
affordability of child care for families
statewide so this report is due june i
think which will set us up nicely
um for the use of potential remaining
american rescue plan funds and then of
course going into the next budget
science cycle uh this committee is well
aware that during the coven 19 pandemic
we saw that the child care workforce
truly is that workforce behind our new
hampshire workforce working folks cannot
go to work if they do not have child
care so as a working mother myself i
have experienced this issue myself in
order and i think it's important to you
know in order to protect the interests
of our working families but also the
interests of our businesses we heard
over in the senate lots of testimony
about how businesses are really
struggling for workers and what they
hear from their workforce what they hear
from their workforce is that one of the
barriers to going back to work and to
staying at work is the availability of
quality and affordable child care
and then when you hear from our child
care facilities the reason why they
cannot keep their doors open the reason
why they can't provide additional slots
is because they don't have the workforce
so you're going to hear a lot about that
today
and i think that this is an important
first step to secure and stabilize uh
our in and hopefully even grow our
workforce to set us up for future
success it's good for families it's good
for business and it's good for our
economy so thank you for your
consideration i'm happy to take
questions but there are plenty more
experts behind me
are there any questions
right
i have a question sure do you really
believe that this can be done by june
30th
well and i'll defer that to department
of health and human services i will say
that you know there is a lot of work
going on in the state not only within
dhhs but within the council for thriving
children all these groups we know that
are working on this so plans are in
place so i you know the bill as
originally written i think was a good
one and so they could just implement
that plan
okay thank you
all right up next i have
dave
is it jubei
from bia to speak for three minutes in
support of the bill
i meant that to be 300 minutes yeah
you're in the wrong room
um madam chair members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to testify
in support of this legislation my name
is dave giubei i'm a senior vice
president for public policy with the
business and industry association i've
been there 22 years and i've never been
before this committee before so it's an
honor for me to be here in support of
this bill i want to talk a little bit
about the bia and why we're here the bia
is a membership organization we
represent employers of all sizes across
the state we have approximately 400
employer members with over 90 000
granite state employees and they're the
reason we're here today because this is
a
constant issue that we hear about from
employers
they're either their inability to hire
because of lack of child care options or
their ability to keep employees because
of child care options
so
we think it's a good idea to take a
closer look at this there has been work
done done on it i think there's
more work that can be done and if
nothing else it will raise this issue
the way workforce housing
became a more important issue uh from
when we started working on that in 2008
back then no one really understood what
workforce housing is now everybody does
i think
the lack of available and affordable
child care is another issue that needs
to be raised in public awareness that
concludes my testimony i hope you'll
pass this bill
thank you so i have one one quick
question if you don't mind
um
would this also look at the reasoning
why child care is so expensive
i um i believe it likely would um i
think
my my impression is
everybody understands why it's so
expensive
the problem is not so much trying to
understand why it's expensive it's
trying to figure out what to do about
that
thank you
representative belanger
thank you madam chair and thank you sir
for being here today and providing your
testimony
prefacing this my question is i'm a
business owner
i i foster a very family-friendly
friendly
um business
i have had chauffeurs bring in their
families while i even myself will watch
their kiddos okay
so
that's what i've done without government
interference so
with the 400 businesses that you
represent what have they done without
government interference because that
should be the first thing that we should
be considering
thank you representative well first of
all i wouldn't characterize establishing
this commission as government
interference but i will tell you what
some of our employers have done when
they have the ability to do so
we've had employers excuse me just this
isn't a commission i i'm confused on
where you're getting that from this this
is this this is a this is a study
kind of thing it's not
i misunderstood the uh the building
thank you
um
some some of our businesses
um have
started their own child care facilities
uh this is uh happening uh
primarily with hospital members because
they have the
resources and the space and the ability
to to do so but it's not
exclusively it is um
a significant
expense for employers to take on but for
those that
that are
either progressive thinking in terms of
what their employees need or those who
are doing it because they see no other
options that is something that is
happening
representative aldshiller
thank you madam chair
thank you very much for being here today
um
so mr dubo can you tell me of these 400
employer members and also welcome to
childhood family we're really thrilled
to have you here of your membership
um do you have
a contingency of child care providers
those business owners as part of your
membership and if you do
what are they telling
the your the group at large i want to
make sure i understand you're asking do
we have child care providers as a part
of our membership exactly yeah we do not
it's not that we're excluding them it's
just um
there is a cost associated with being a
bi member and i think they have other
things that are more critical for them
to spend their resources on
we we do however hear from them in in
terms of we have a policy committee
within the bia called the human
resources and workforce development
committee and we frequently
invite in as guests either advocates for
uh child care in general or from time to
time people who actually run child care
facilities to just talk about the
challenges that they face
i think you may ask a follow-up question
so within your um hr and workforce
development committee where you're you
know bringing in i'm assuming
correct me if i'm wrong these are like
luncheon learns or your
business
your executive board members
um when you're saying that like they're
you're bringing in
people who own ch own child care
facilities to talk yeah it's it's more
formal than luncheon learns it's less
formal than the executive committee what
it is is a monthly uh policy committee
we start meeting in september and then
we go through the legislative session
it's made up entirely of members of the
bia primarily those that work in
human resources fields like human
resources managers or vps but also
people who work in the healthcare
industries and
people who
specialize in workforce development
um
the purpose of the committee is to look
at bills like this and others affecting
those areas
and get input from our members about
the efficacy of the legislation and
that's that's sort of the initial step
of how bia establishes policy
last last follow-up okay thank you very
much so uh i think what i'm mostly
curious about because i know many of
your members
and um in my district we have
a number of child care facilities and
not a week goes by where i don't hear
from either a child care facility
or
people who work and need child care and
there's disconnects in cost in
availability particularly availability
and i'm wondering
i'm really glad that the bia is taking
an interest
have you done your own research so far
and what are you bringing to the table
now
because you've been dealing i know that
you have been dealing with this as an
issue for a lot longer than this bill
has been a bill yeah so
the perspective i get from our members
it's more candidly it's more of an
availability issue than a cost issue and
i'll explain why
you have to be a certain type of company
regardless of your size you have to be a
certain type of company to to belong to
the bia just because
we're a membership organization so you
have to be willing to
um
be willing to invest in an organization
like that which is generally
uh more well-established companies or
companies that that are not struggling
in order to meet payroll
so in general those types of firms have
better paying jobs for their employees
so it's not
from our perspective for our members
it's not necessarily a cost issue it's
more an availability issue and i'll give
you one quick example i have a colleague
whose name
was david career he was a lobbyist here
worked on energy and environmental
issues in in the legislature
um you know none of us are going to get
rich working at the bia but you know
we're paid here either
just saying here either yeah you know
we're not scraping
either
and he had it while he was at the bi he
had a little baby little baby girl and
about six months before
the the birth of that child they started
looking around for
uh child care opportunities because his
wife also works um and they got put on
waiting lists they live in newington and
they you know went
square miles around looking for child
care so he worked for me for about a
year and a half and then he left he now
works at eversource down in manchester
from the time he started with me to the
time he left
he was still looking for a child care
opportunity and they were doing what
they needed to do to get by sometimes he
would stay in work from home sometimes
his wife would stay and work from home
sometimes the in-laws were there but
that's how difficult it is for someone
who has the resources to find child care
are you
upset are there any further questions
seeing none thank you very much
up next is henry bayou bay you
from the new hampshire alliance of ymca
since we can support the bill for two
minutes
um thank you very much madam chair and
members of the committee for the record
my name is henry valu
and i'm here on behalf of the new
hampshire alliance of ymcas
if you take all the
different y facilities around the state
manchester nashua concord keene
seacoast londonderry
and you add them all together we're one
of the largest child care providers
in the state and
we certainly experience
the trials and tribulations that this
bill is trying to address
the bill as introduced in the senate was
a pretty comprehensive bill uh which ran
into some glitches and
um so we uh supported senator bradley uh
who chairs the um
senate health human services committee
uh sort of put together the version that
you have before you today
which basically is going to get the
right parties together
um to try to put together a plan and i
think a lot of the work has been done
already um so there are pieces that can
be taken so
you know i'm i'm somewhat optimistic
that by june 30
um the parties can get agreement on
something uh it would then be presented
to the legislature
probably through the
the uh the fiscal committee um
and uh have some legislative review uh
in that regard too so
but we are strong support of the bill
and happy to take any
questions are there any questions
seeing none thank you very much
up next is karen hebert
from dhhs to speak for five minutes
good afternoon my name is karen hebert i
am the director for the division of
economic and housing stability for the
department of health and human services
so this particular bill is essentially
to create a plan
that would identify sustainable
solutions to strengthen the child care
profession
what we need is a multi-faceted approach
to try to strengthen that profession so
the department has been already
initiated
meetings with the child care advisory
council i'm encouraged by those
conversations
we will continue to meet i am optimistic
that we will be able to meet the june
30th deadline
the child care
the bureau of child development and head
start collaboration is one of the
bureaus that i oversee that has been
working tirelessly
on a three-phased approach to strengthen
the child care profession and this is
all as a result of the pandemic the
first phase that we engaged in was
really about
the emergency response
the second phase was all about recovery
and stabilization
we are now in that third phase where
we're looking at long-term
sustainability
long-term stabilization and capacity
building
for the industry for the profession when
i say long term that doesn't necessarily
mean
initiatives that would take a long time
to get to it includes
what we use the word rapidly
there are some ideas that we're already
discussing to address a rapid response
as a result of this particular bill
what the long term essentially means is
sustainable
what are the sustainable solutions that
will help child care providers perhaps
help them to increase
wages and earnings of
their workforce
so i'm happy to answer any questions you
may have
are there any questions
representative lebeck
yes uh thank you for taking my question
um
so we've seen a lot of young families
entering into new hampshire and part of
the problem is finding
child care for their kids uh would you
see
the outcome of this benefiting those
young families entering in so that way
they can find an easier access to that
the intent is to
to do just that i mean really
strengthening the entire industry
strengthening the profession so that we
can accommodate people who need child
care including the employer community so
one of the ideas of course is being able
to partner more with the employer
community to do exactly that
representative
thank you madam chair i have a
clarifying question you had just
mentioned um and thank you very thank
you very much i'm sorry i'm just leaping
right ahead
um when you were talking about the
three-phase approach to strengthening
child care in new hampshire is that a
report that a committee put together
that's already available
i would be more than happy to share that
with you yes yes what was the name of
that commitment was in my notes i i know
you said that there was a group that
evaluated those that three-phase
approach it's the the bureau of child
development and head start collaboration
i'm sorry the speaker is in our way no
worries
um which is a bureau that i oversee in
the department
the bureau of child development and head
start collaboration thank you yes
just a long it is a long title
and may a follow-up match and so um this
working group
already has um
you've already put together
some data that could
inform
this this uh the
what this bill is asking for by the june
30th deadline we do have some data and i
think that it's important that we try to
identify other data sets that are
available
so that we can really make an informed
decision for the legislature going
forward sure
um last follow-up so i guess what i'm
what i'm driving at is you're not you're
not reinventing the wheel now you
already have stuff that you're working
on and you know what you need to find
so
that's correct yes awesome so june 30th
is not a daunting deadline necessarily
no ma'am awesome thank you
are there any further questions
seeing them thank you very much thank
you up next is jackie cowell to speak in
support of the bill for two minutes from
early learning new hampshire
good afternoon how do you do madam chair
and members of the committee i'm jackie
cowell from early learning new hampshire
we're a statewide non-profit that works
to help
child care programs do their work as
this the workforce and the families they
serve
and so
just here briefly to point out that we
are in support of this bipartisan
amendment it um passed as a bipartisan
amendment to again go for the pro go
from an appropriation from gopher state
discretionary funds to a plan
to do that and we are in support of that
we do hope the legislature in the house
will also agree
to support this
development of a plan by dhhs in
consultation with the new hampshire
child care advisory council you'll hear
from some of their leadership here it's
a legislatively enacted group
to advise the department so we do
believe it's very important to have this
plan about how to to increase the
retention and recruitment and have it
again as a bipartisan came through the
senate it'd be great to have the house
also put their
stamp on it and say we we think this
plan should happen as well i think that
will be very important i brought with me
simply
some more testimony
stay work play
also has has child care is one of its
top priorities of affordability and
availability i've got their testimony
they couldn't be here
fred coker who
runs new hampshire's business on wmur
did a bipartisan senator whitley and
senator hennessey were on his show
earlier in the year talking about the
importance of retention and recruitment
of the child care workforce i have that
testimony from him for today and i'm
just sharing with you really quickly
this other um back in january when this
first came out um we have over 1 000
almost 1 900 signatures from parents
from child care programs and from over
190 businesses here in new hampshire
saying please
let's add this tool to our toolbox this
plan for retention and recruitment and
look to gopher
for availability of funds and again what
would happen after the plan is submitted
as said in the amendment to the
governor's office the speaker of the
house the president of the senate and
the fiscal committee just like any other
go for state funds it would go to fiscal
committee to then be passed and
appropriated thank you
are there any questions
saying none thank you
up next is marianne barter who to speak
in support of the bill for two minutes
from the child care advisory council
thank you very much i'm mary ann barter
i'm the chair of the child care advisory
council um and i'm in support of the
child care advisory council is in
support of this bill i just want to take
a couple of minutes to explain why this
bill is so important the funding that
has gone to child care facilities for
the last couple of years has helped
stabilize individual agencies and
programs but this but this bill presents
child care without borders it's really
an opportunity to keep the workforce in
the workforce so that if there's a
reason why a child care provider chooses
to leave their center or their program
they're incentivized to go to another
child care program or agency rather than
target or dunkin donuts or something
else or retail establishment it's really
to incentivize people to stay in the
field until things can improve and i
think we all truly believe that things
will improve but it will get it will
take time um three years from now i
think the child care
industry will be well on its way to
sustainability and some practices that
will really incentivize people to enter
the field and stay there but we are not
there yet so we need to maintain our
workforce until we can get there
one of the things that is truly
important about this bill right now is
that maine recently
put in their budget 12 million dollars
worth of incentives for child care
providers and massachusetts is looking
at 60 million dollars worth of incentive
for child care
providers the individual teachers
we want to maintain our workforce
and we also want to make sure that our
workforce stays in new hampshire the
last thing we want is for the very
talented people that we have who are
willing to continue working in this
field decide to drive to mainer
massachusetts to do it so this is truly
important
um and i'd also like to say that i agree
with karen hebert our colleague at dhhs
the child care advisory council is very
optimistic that we will be able to meet
the june 30th deadline but i do believe
that passing this bill will ensure that
we meet the june 30th deadline
and that's all
are there any questions
all right seeing none thank you very
much thank you so much up next is mark
mcmurphy
to speak in support of the bill for two
minutes from white birch center
thank you madam chair and thanks to the
committee for allowing me to testify
i got into child care not out of passion
um
i was in business
for the first 25 years of my career and
then i was serving on a board
asked to serve on a board at white birch
center and
i ended up becoming the executive
director and my passion has grown quite
a bit
with all the business experience that i
have and and having an mba i was able to
do a lot of work at white birch to get
our finances organized and do all of the
proper budgeting that any business
should do and
having done all of that um why is child
care expensive what's i heard you asked
that madam chair
it
it has to be even more expensive really
to make it work for long-term stability
because otherwise
you just can't pay the workforce what
you need to pay
for them to turn it into a career
and
to be stable and unlike
um some other options if uh if a
restaurant is short on labor
in our town of henniker great town
there's a few other restaurants so if
they're closed on tuesdays you can go to
another restaurant but with child care
that's not an option
for a lot of families and to stabilize
the workforce
and to keep them in place and to have a
place for working families
this bill which i support uh
takes steps in that direction and i
think that's really healthy not just for
working families but for the economy i'd
love to see
the economy stay strong in new hampshire
and not have it falter
i know housing is an issue but child
care is also a very big issue and this
bill helps to address that
are there any questions
and then thank you so much
up next is shannon trembley
to speak in support of the bill for two
minutes from little blessings
hey thank you my name is shannon
tremblay i'm the director of little
blessings child care center in
portsmouth as well as the vice chair of
the child care advisory council
thank you for listening to our testimony
today
i miss the days
of classrooms full of children and
meeting new families as they come to
tour our center in hopes of being able
to enroll their child little blessings
has always had the reputation for long
wait lists because of our wonderful care
unfortunately now we have long wait
lists because we don't have staff
these days i walk by dark in classrooms
where children were once happily engaged
in fun learning activities
mornings are spent hoping that nobody's
called out or and rearranging schedules
in order to meet state ratios
our enrollment is down by 60 percent we
haven't been able to enroll any new
families in our program in over a year
due to staffing we're barely making room
for new siblings of our older children
without staff we can't open classrooms
without staff we can't enroll children
without staff we cannot meet the needs
of families who desperately are looking
for care
when i first started at little blessings
we had roughly 25 staff
full and part-time
we currently have 12 and only four of
those are qualified teachers we're
thankful for every day we don't have to
close another classroom or lose another
staff member
the effects of the pandemic continue to
hit hard the past two years have been a
roller coaster ride and not the happy
fun one
this one's white knuckle dark scary
loop-de-loop ride with twists and turns
you can't see coming
directors and teachers are exhausted
emotionally mentally and physically it's
a struggle to put your whole heart and
soul in your career every day only to be
left feeling like you're on your own
little island and nobody speaks your
language
this bill has not come at a better time
we cannot afford to lose any more valued
teachers in fact this bill has the
ability to strengthen and rebuild new
hampshire's child care workforce
i've been getting calls from hr
departments who are looking to hire
candidates but that person cannot find
child care and therefore cannot accept
the position
every day we have an average of six to
eight calls or emails from parents
desperately looking for child care we
must tell them that we don't have any
idea when we will have an opening as it
all depends on being able to find hire
and retain staff we need this bill new
hampshire's child care industry needs
this bill new hampshire's families need
this bill thank you for your time today
and your continued support
are there any questions
saying none thank you very much
up next is corlyn
hoppy
happy to speak for two minutes from the
rochester child care center
thank you i appreciate your guys time
um i'm corlyn hoppy i'm the executive
director of rochester child care center
i'm a newbie i've only been doing this
for seven months but i have my master's
degree and i understand the business
world
i work to collaborate with many outside
industries to make sure that we offer
care but at this point i have 40 babies
to toddlers on our wait list
i have 90 employees under me
and we're still not able to pay them or
compete with any under industry i give
our lead teachers have bachelor's degree
between 17 and 22 dollars an hour
in the state of new hampshire rent is
1400 a month if you are not married like
myself with an electrician i'm not able
to work or be able to stay in this field
so as an agency we're okay and we are
going to make it
but we've had three other centers closed
down right near us
so beginning the beginning of may
our wait list will probably jump up
between 60 and 70.
so we're already at the point of chaos
and we want to come to you as a point of
an opportunity this is the first time
you can really truly invest in families
and children agencies like mine in order
to keep our people here because we're
going to get to a point that we run them
all off and no one wants to hang out
here
so i've talked to the mayor over in
rochester and been involved in a lot of
the rotary conversations about the
building of the cities but i in another
child care center and a few small family
child care centers are the only ones in
town
and i'm not sure how much longer those
other ones are going to make it
so the reason rochester child care works
is because we have a large school age
program our school age program offsets
the cost of our early child care program
which would put us into debt if we
didn't have
not we're okay for early child care
teachers right now in our actual agency
but our school age program is suffering
and it's really that program that pays
our teachers and for our administrative
costs so we're at a point where just in
constant putting out buyers
if you give us the opportunity to have
this plan and have real discussions with
the state we might in turn be able to
thrive again and really help the rest of
our economy but for right now we're
pinning parents against agencies we're
competing with other child care
industries indirectly because of two
hires i've shut down classrooms and
other agencies
so um
i'm here
in three different hats as a parent of
two children we're struggling to stay in
this state
as an executive director of an agency
and as a person of
new hampshire
so if you could i i hope that you guys
would just invest in our children and
families and continue to help new
hampshire stay
thank you
are there any questions
sing none thank you so much
up net up next is um linua
lynn roulette to speak for two minutes
representing nellie's treehouse
thank you for having me um and thank you
for taking the time to listen to us
you've heard from my colleagues we're
all in the same boat um i'm in a center
of 70 children i have a wait list of 77
children i get daily calls from parents
when will you know can i get a space how
can i get in
um it's horrible to have to tell a
parent i don't know
we're short staffed i work a 13-hour day
to support my staff
and they don't make enough money to
support themselves
we've raised their their benefits we've
raised their wages we're doing
everything we can but when you can go to
mcdonald's and make 25 an hour or 20 an
hour
and it's a little bit easier than having
to sit with a bunch of children all day
these are our future
these children are our future they're
our future workforce
and if we can't support them and their
families we won't have a workforce we
won't have a future workforce
and my colleagues and i will struggle to
survive
we hope that you'll take this bill into
great consideration
new hampshire families need our help our
children need consistent educated
qualified individuals to take care of
them not a babysitter i'm not a
babysitter i don't sit on babies
i am a child care worker
i take care of children all day
when their parents need to work
it is the foundation of their education
and it is the future of our state and
what better to put your money into than
the future of our state
thank you very much
are there any questions
seeing them thank you
up next is
devin
is it quinn or owen i can't make out the
last name i apologize
okay
um
to speak in support of the bill she does
have written testimony from the new
hampshire women's foundation
she asked for i think three minutes i
think i can do it less than that
chair members of the committee excuse me
my name is devin quinn and i'm coming
from the new hampshire women's
foundation um in addition to the
previous testimony before me i just
wanted to add to the discussion uh the
specific impact the child care crisis
has on women um women make up 86 of
child care workers in industry in the
field itself
but among essential
care work uh essential
workforce it's 68
that means women are the majority of
social services health care grocery
retail convenience stores and the thing
about all those jobs is that
they can't do it from home they can't do
that work from home and when child care
is an issue when they call out that's
ripple effects throughout the entire
economy
and certainly child care impacts a whole
family but we've seen during kovid when
um most families for at some point lost
uh school or child care um it was
actually four mothers were four to five
times more likely to reduce their hours
or completely
leave the workforce to take care of
child care
15 percent of new hampshire workers who
would be in the workforce
who are not
cite child care
issues as the main reason why they're
not in the workforce
and when women leave the workforce they
that is impacting their career
trajectory
it's impacting their financial security
moving forward
uh women have always been the backbone
of the workforce working outside the
home working inside the home
taking care of children inside the home
and outside the home
so this bill would not only support the
economy and the sector but specifically
women as well
thank you
are there any questions
seeing none thanks so much thank you
and that folks is a wrap
so i'm going to close the public hearing
on senate bill 446
and
we will come back at
3 10.
yep
thank you
good
foreign
um
one
oh really
i think
okay
chitchat
is
you want to know
i
why don't you just do what other
communities have done kim and say this
was drafted in error
that it i meant for it to say six
and if the committee is good with that
then you can get the final performance
i mean committees have done that
yes
and the one that kim showed me before
does have the 254 languages
okay
oh it's in my hand
so unfortunately um
aha there it is okay hold on one second
bear with me everybody
unfortunately we're gonna have to come
back next tuesday morning
we'll have time to get 458 out because
we have to get that out today but um
unfortunately we're gonna have to come
back next tuesday
sorry
we'll probably do 458 and um 446
and then we'll come back and finish out
the rest
next week
so just bear with me one second
where did it go
could i please get 25 copies
so karen i just sent
an amendment upstairs to be printed
do you have time to make sure she gets
that email
thank you
okay
so we'll start with um
senate bill 446.
uh representative nelson do you have a
motion
thank you madam chair yes
my motion is out to pass
do we have a second
second manager seconded by
representative belanger
discussion
so i'm just gonna say i think this is
going to be really informative and
really helpful
so i'm happy to see that
that this will go forward
is there any more
discussion representative yokela
um
[Music]
can't they make this plan without having
a bill
i mean is that is there
a need for having a bill to say make a
plan well i think that they do in order
to bring a plant to fiscal
perhaps maybe it just holds their feet
to the fire
is there any further discussion
okay seeing none i'll have the clerk
call the role
no
representative nelson
yes
representative belanger
representative cross
representative litchfield
yes
representative
smith
representative long yes representative
alessia yes
representative grossman
yes representative levesque yes
representative
netting wong yes
representative altschuler yes
representative petrino i'll be voting
yes madam chair rice yes
motion passes do you have any objection
to it going on consent
no
okay so without objection that will go
on a consent calendar
what was the final count please 13
1 1 thank you
okay
so next up is um
senate bill 458
um
do i have a do i have a motion
representative belanger
yes madam chair i move otp
okay
second so the motion is otp right yet we
have to introduce the i apologize i said
otp and then i was like
okay
so
i'm i'm just waiting for the copies to
come down
um so
the
um amendment that i put in puts 458 back
in place adds sb 254 which were the
condition reducing the conditions of
confinement at sysc but it also
um starts with a six-bed facility
and the thinking is then the
finance committee can negotiate up if
they would like
but i would really like a strong showing
of support from this committee that we
do not think it is okay to put kids in
jail
but yet they'll still have a facility
for the worst offenders
did i explain that okay
so i'm just waiting for that i do have i
have copies of the amendment that say
the 12 bed facility
but um
if you want to start looking at it but
every 12 is going to be replaced with a
6. so question for me yes so
uh hospital 254 i'm our um
what what's the bill that's in there oh
yeah hb 254. okay hb 250 that's the one
that we voted out on the conditions yeah
and um
the amendment has six
yep six beds yep
and
um
is it
are the six beds
privately ran nope they'll be run by the
state by dhhs so the six beds
will be run by the state
yeah and is there a um is there a limbo
period still with respect to sending
kids out of state if
the facility's not built before they
shut down the cemetery no i don't
believe so
i mean i can let you look at this one if
you want just just keep in mind that it
it's um 12 beds i mean it's six beds not
12. right yep
did you guys want to look at these
or wait for the other one so we don't
get confused
i'm sorry i got a mess
yeah i'm just i'm just waiting i sent it
up there karen's going to bring it down
as soon as it's ready
nope not that one these are nothing
there they are
yes please
okay
yeah no those are
trash
i believe i voted against 254 in this
committee
you probably did
because it says 14 to 1 out of the
committee and i think i vaguely remember
that's me
so that's
interesting so you'll probably vote
against this right
madam chair
yes
that wasn't good i i know that wasn't
the chair
[Laughter]
yes
representative alessia um
i haven't read through the whole thing
as yet
i probably should wait in this question
so everything's the same except for is
six beds instead of 12 bed
that was in the other amendment yeah
in the previous amendment okay
so we've combined
like all three thought processes right
we've combined the the 458 as it
originally was
with
sb 254 which we passed out of here that
reduces the offenses for placement okay
at sununu and we've added the six bed
facility
and then
we'll let finance take it from there
okay my question is
so suppose they're
eight
individuals so
they can what i would like to see in the
design
is perhaps um and i had talked to
director ribsum about this before is
temporary walls space a little extra
space so that they could manipulate the
so-called pods
right
when in case so say you had you know two
two and two if you needed four and two
you could
you can mix it up
okay
and
it's going to be done still the time
period still the same time frame
um i'm fine i would like to say i would
like to see it sooner but that's
something that we can
probably leave to finance because by the
time they get it they'll have a better
aspect of the price of everything and
what they're going to be
able to do
i feel dirty but then you do why do you
feel dirty because i don't think it's
one finance that part i think that we
well i'm my only concern is if we
change that date to make it sooner
then we leave ourselves in a position
where children may have to be
placed out of state and we don't want
that to happen you know um
that's that's my feeling on it while i
don't want it to go that far
i don't want to see kids sent out of
state either because we have to close
sununu not
anyone have available other yes she just
passed out
madam chair yes i'm sorry i was just
hoping that
the six is half of the twelve so it will
cut the time down and we could at least
do that
if we had the six we could it could cut
the time down but
i just i don't see that happening it's
government
you know
everything just takes forever
i feel like
do you know what i mean
and then if we do move the time frame do
you have another copy
oh my god
i think there's more
um i'm sorry go ahead i apologize
oh i was just throwing things out
because
first was 18 then they said 12 and then
if we went with the six then i was
hoping that
that would i know
i would too but i also worry i mean
there
i i know of stick kids right now that
it's gonna be more
but you know i mean so here is my huge
issue right
do we put juveniles who adults who
create misdemeanors are they put in jail
for some of these offenses these kids
are being put in jail and we don't even
put adults in jail half the time
you know so i just
i try not to get emotional over this but
i can't help but think about all those
cases of how many people whose lives
were ruined ruined
because
they were placed at sununu and what
happened to them because there are
lifelong
issues drug addiction how many of them
died from suicide or drug overdoses
because they were trying to cope with
what happened to them i don't want that
ever
to happen again
i just can't even stand it
and i i'm sorry i'm getting emotional
but it's just something that just tears
me up
we were supposed to be looking out for
them and we failed tremendously
so i apologize
and i'm a little bit of a mess these
days anyway so
you know
no i appreciate if i may
yes please appreciate your honesty
but
and i'm very immersed emotional about it
as well
um i do work with sex offenders as you
know yep
i know and um
i i'm just
i'm nervous i don't want to set them up
to fail right because because of the
past
not um
watching
the hen house as they should have been
right i don't want them to suffer
you know what i mean i don't i do a
rush
decision
because of
what we know happened
right right unfortunately so
i've been working on this all week
um it's just it stinks that it has to be
out of the committee today you know what
i mean that's the part that stinks
so
i you know
i feel good with the six beds and giving
finance time to look everything over and
if they want to raise it a little they
can
but i want us to send a strong message
to them
huh
yeah right
so i just you know that's that's where i
am with it um
[Music]
just
i mean
representative elsia do you do you have
anything else
or is there something you would like me
to change i mean i can send in for
another amendment
of course
i hope i have it i hope i have an answer
and i'm not trying to stall but my
question is what would happen if it went
to
interim study could the kids still stay
there until oh no
that facility has to close that's the
clothes yeah
so
um that's why
that's why we have to work really
closely with
representative wallner
so that we you know i mean like she said
she's been
doing this for years you know
she's got the whole finance committee to
to work with too right so i mean
i just feel like
i know what you're saying i do know what
you're saying
i totally get it
i really do thank you
so yes go ahead the um
the amendment doesn't reference research
base either
right oh well i see it no idea
is that good oh that's fine that's
something we may want to okay we may
want that's something we can change
later on though right because we've got
time for that
great
right
yeah
representative ocala
thank you um it's
so it's already in law that it's going
to be closed um
that was in hb2 and so that's already
the the paradigm that we're living in
and so if we didn't if we interim
studied this then it would just close
without a plan kind of a thing right we
need a plan and so that that is that is
obviously a concern um and and as far as
the
the um
research-based stuff i looked at 170 and
it seemed like there was a lot of
options as far as
um
stuff that
is
not just
it it talked about things that were not
just um
uh
evidence-based it talked about uh more
things than that so i'm not sure that
that should be a sticking point
but um
but obviously i'm not sure that i'm
going to uh i
i
didn't support 254 and
so i'm not going to support support 254
now
so um
why am i not surprised
that is
all that i have to say on that thanks
okay
representative litchfield
thank you
can you please just walk me through the
beds one more time so we listened to
testimony several times this morning
where we currently have 12 children so i
hear what you're saying but
what happens if we need
12 beds what happened to those other six
children potentially go out of state i
mean they're not necessarily going to be
let go so
with
um sb 254
i do believe that will help bring the
census down but it will also send the
lesser offenders
to
the community-based treatment
places rather than
the jail
did that answer your question
representative smith
so are you proposing the six beds for
what we talked about earlier like just
for felons
just for the major felonies that
kids
would it be like the kids who
are charged as adults yeah that for a
place for them to be with without being
in adult jail
adult prison
okay
yes a representative yokela i'm sorry i
apologize um so
um
there there's um
i guess a discussion to be had about
whether or not um
detained people because right now a
significant number of people at the
sununu center are not actually committed
there they're just detained and so do
they have to be
um detained
in this six beds facility i don't think
that's necessarily the case they could
be detained elsewhere and so we so
um
the 12 people may are is including the
number of detained people and not and so
that may be a factor to bring in and um
just in reference to
representative smith's comment um it's
not just felonies it's
violent felonies that are because we're
still letting
regular felonies that are not classified
like in this legislation
um as violent essentially um
to not be uh committed
so
those those felonies under adult
situations may
may actually lead to jail time
if they were an adult
but the felonies
under um 254 hb 254 would still let them
not be committed
thank you
and you know
i just i really would just like to see
us setting these kids up for success
that's that's really
i think the most important thing is we
want them to succeed
and we want to give them the tools that
they need to succeed
and i think that
we have the ability to do that without
jail
representative de simone
thank you madam chair
i think that one of the parts of this
discussion that we're missing is the
fact that last year
um
the governor
set aside some monies for juvenile
diversion programs
and that's where a lot of kids are going
to be dealt with
who are not violent
committing violent felony crimes
so with the governor's money going to
juvenile diversion programs
um we're helping
my my
um
full disclosure here my program
sees hundreds of kids a year that would
normally go to the sununu center
but they go through diversion programs
and
they're successful and it's set that
program sets them up for success
um i've had many kids come back to me
and say guess what
i just graduated college or did this and
i just got a management position in this
facility that i'm working in and whatnot
and so forth
these are kids that are going through
diversion so that money is being well
spent
having said that since that money is
going there
and the sununu center has to close done
deal
i think that we need to realize that the
amount of kids that would be going to
sununu center
is decreasing due to the diversion
programs
so there is the room for the felons
thank you
representative
uh yeah i i get the community based
services yeah however what is acceptable
for a waiting time for a child that
needs those services and that's in your
bigger municipalities like manchester
nashua
um there's waiting there's wait time you
know this child needs this this this
service great uh
we'll have an opening in a month
i you know is that
i
i mean i i prefer that when a child
needs services
the next day
um so when we look at community base you
know we have put money into community
base however
your larger municipalities it's usually
split up
through municipality and your larger
communities which have the heavier um
uh the heavier
caseload
you know where we're short
uh capacity
you know we don't we don't have the
capacity so so
i you know
i mean i get that i get this amendment
and i'm gonna support it
um
but when we talk about community-based
treatment let's be sure that
every community
has community-based treatment that a
child doesn't have to wait a month to
get into you know
right
that's a good point
thank you
so is there
um
any further discussion representative
aldshiller
thank you madam chair could you clarify
for me because um
i i
in in
either version of the bill they're both
the same in this particular point
um but i'll refer to the amendment that
you just passed out page three line
thirty page three
is the sum of one dollar there so that
the finance committee can decide how
much gopher and how much
general care okay thank you that's i and
and i know that they had said they
wanted us to put in the the 15 million
but i think that we leave that dollar
amount
for um finance to figure out what
they're gonna need
um
you know we're just really not the money
people so i think but by placing that
dollar in there it gives them a line to
put the money in
is there any further discussion
oh representative belanger
thank you madam chair
honestly i don't know where to begin
i started my journey in the legislature
this year
prior to that
i was a victim
at the student center
this
despite
the process
this is
the best solution moving forward
and i encourage you all
to support this amendment
it is not the best
situation
but i support it
i don't agree with privatizing the
facility
i believe the state needs to own it
i don't believe in locking kids up
one of those kids
probably one of the most successful kids
out of that facility say one of
we can be better
and by we i mean
kids in that situation
we're not bad kids we all hear that
we all know that
so
that's uh all i wanted to say with that
madam chair thank you for the point of
privilege
thank you cody thank you for sharing
is there any further discussion
all right so um did i move the amendment
i don't think i did so i move amendment
two zero two two one four seven zero h
we've had our discussion it's been
seconded by representative desimone
and when the clerk's ready we're we're
voting on the amendment right now
representative this amount yes
representative yo keller
no
representative nelson
yes representative belanger
yes
representative
cross is not with us representative
litchfield yes representative smith yes
representative long yes representative
alessia yes representative grossman
yes representative levesque yes
representative nutting wong
yes representative
reluctantly
yes representative petrino i will be
voting yes madam chair rice
yes
motion passes 13 to 1.
so now you make the motion
madam chair and make motion otpa
do we have a second
oh seconded by representative long
okay
is there any further discussion
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role
what i'm oh i'm sorry i didn't see you
thank you madam chair
i i just want to
i'm uncomfortable that we're
that we haven't had any time to process
this and to
just
to think about this
in less than an hour um
so
i preface my votes and my questions on
being feeling very very rushed and
feeling i feel i feel just as rushed um
i think the timeline stinks that the
time frame that we have to get this done
because it goes to a second committee
and we didn't get this until last week
and they were sending it straight to
finance and i said oh no
that's coming to children and family law
first
so just to clarify on line 17 of the
amendment we just adopted which page i'm
sorry page one page one oh yeah okay
this ydc will be operated by the state
yes
and the oversight will be by the state
okay
thank you
is there any further discussion
all right sing none
i'll ask the clerk to call the role the
motion is ought to pass as amended
representative
yes
representative yokela no
i didn't hear that i apologize
no
i assumed but i still didn't hear it
okay thank you
representative nelson yes
representative belanger
yes representative cross is not with us
representative litchfield yes
representative smith yes
representative long yes representative
alicea
yes
representative grossman
yes representative levesque
yes representative nutting wong yes
representative although
again reluctantly yes
representative petrino i will be voting
yes madam chair rice yes
motion carries 13-1
thank you all so much
and
so then we'll be back to finish out the
rest of them um
next tuesday at 10 o'clock
and uh
we'll try to whiz right through right so
we can be done
okay
10 o'clock yep can you pass that to cody
you